Pow,
POW.
Pow.
I get so pumped up for these,
uh,
fight companion.
If you've never heard one of these before.
Ladies and gentlemen,
and I'll probably explain this in the introduction for the people that have to
listen to the audio version of it only,
uh,
we just watch fights and we talk shit.
We may or may not discuss the actual fight itself.
Uh,
most of the time we don't,
but today it's with the Great Joe.
He motherfucking Diaz.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks for being here brother.
I'm excited and I'm excited about our show at the Cock theater tomorrow night.
Yes.
Out of all the fights on the card.
Go sign.
Yos Alvarez was the fight.
Really.
I was Mike for the whole weekend,
the whole weekend.
I didn't know when it was.
I thought it was one on the,
on the car and I didn't know what it was.
Yeah.
This one tonight I've been waiting for this to me is a fucking barn burner.
I'm looking forward to it for sure.
Cause Alvarez is a very tough and he makes every fight tough.
He's a tough dude and I think he's going to have a real good game plan coming
in.
I think he's going to be as prepared as you've ever going to see him.
Cause you've seen him off some hard fights in the UFC.
You know,
he had,
uh,
that war with cowboy Serone got got lit up,
especially his leg,
his leg kicked.
He just got introduced to the next level of MMA,
but coming off of a victory like that over pedes and he beat Gilbert two and a,
he,
if I had to fight through adversity in the Gilbert Melendez Phi data,
seriously fucked up.
I remember his eyes.
Yes,
that's right.
It's a tough,
he could talk dude.
You gotta you know,
you got to put him away man.
And that's tough to fucking do.
He says game as they get,
but this dude is special.
There's still San Joses special.
He's,
um,
he's hit a very high level over the last couple of years and he's,
his skill level is higher than it's ever been.
It's like a bunch of different things coming together.
One,
it's hot.
Cordero Hofeld Cordura is such a good coach.
The coach of kings MMA,
the one,
the original guys from shoot debox in Cotati ba Brazil.
Those guys were so bad ass.
I mean,
he's from such a bad ass lineage.
He's from the early days of Ninja and Anderson Silva and he's the guy who took
for breach over doom from a guy,
really wasn't a striker at all,
just a Jujitsu artists.
And he brought him to the heavyweight title and now you look at Fabrizio
striking,
he made a big mistake obviously in the steep meo chick fight.
But I think Steven Meo chicks a bad motherfucker.
If he catches you,
he catches you.
You know,
he tried to go to war with Steve pay and Steve Bay just was better at moving
away and countering them and he got careless and left some openings and it could
have been because he was in Brazil.
He was a real emotional,
you know,
who knows.
He fucked up and Steve Bay is a bad motherfucker.
So those two are a bad combination together.
But that said,
you look at like for doom striking against Travis Browne's.
Excellent.
His strike against Cain Velasquez.
Excellent,
excellent long snaps that jab out,
keeps you to distance,
throws hard kicks because he wants you to take him down.
How that he wants you put him on his back.
Good luck with that.
Good luck with the nastiest guard the heavyweight division has ever seen.
Arguably he's a motherfucker.
I mean Frank Mir snapped arms.
I mean you've got to go with like,
if you want to look at it like effective submissions in the heavyweight division
in MMA,
it's tough to not give the nod to frank.
Mir tapped Lesner with a knee bar snap mataros arm snapped Tim Silvia's arm.
Just maybe not for his overall career cause he's,
he's definitely had ups and downs but been in some amazing fights.
But his submission victories are fucking horrendous.
He breaks bones,
man.
Who the fuck else breaks bones?
Frank Mir is breaking bones with a armbars breaking bones with Kimora.
He poked fucking minute Toros arm snapped it in half where he was looking over
at it like holy Shit.
So it's hard not to give the nod to,
to Frank Mir when it comes to like overall MMA guard skill.
But that said,
man,
the technical ability that VRE doom has is off the charts.
The way he wraps you up is so neat.
He just tucks everything tight like that fader Armbar all my God.
I mean he just slapped that on him or Fado was stuck in that guard and you could
see in his eyes he was like,
Oh shit.
Like this is like the water's heavier.
I can't drink it.
Like,
oh,
I can't,
I can't get up to get where the air is.
Holy Shit.
It just get crushed into those legs and he's fucking huge too.
He's a giant guy.
I'm going to go legit.
Two 40 doesn't really have to lift much to be like two 40 he's a huge guy
for dooms.
No joke,
man.
So for steep immuno chick to take him out like that.
Fuck.
That was a victory.
And to do it in Brazil,
it must've been nuts,
man.
There was like 40,000 people or something crazy.
Ryan was a soccer stadium.
Jesus.
He went,
he didn't give a fuck.
There was zero fucks given him zero fucks given me.
Oh Jeez.
World.
There was zero fucks.
He had no idea he was in Brazil.
Well,
he's,
that dude is as live shit as they get.
His mindset is so strong.
He's so calm.
Right before he throws down man.
And you know what?
More now than ever because he's been there and done that.
That war that he had with junior dos Santos,
I mean that was a fucking war.
Experiences a motherfucking this UFC and MMA experiences it man.
Yeah,
it is it.
But he's also got a lot of skill and he's getting better.
That's the other thing about steep by steep banks getting better.
I mean,
he's always been a motherfucker,
but he's better now than he's ever been.
Better mentally stronger,
more steady.
Like everything about it is better now.
He has,
what's his name in Cleveland?
When ouster Overeem in October.
Oh,
September.
Something like September I think.
September in Cleveland.
Oh,
we want to go to a barn burner on com.
I don't know what the date is.
Let's do it a show him Friday night.
October is jacked until there's a,
it's too God damn popular.
No,
no,
no.
I do the every other week thing,
but the nose,
the special,
everything is just falling,
you know,
it's just,
uh,
October 15th I shoot.
So everything is wrapped around that pretty much beautiful.
But Cleveland's a,
that's going to be fun.
And they're the people that are going to be there to support Steve Bay because
right now,
I mean they've got basketball and now they've got the UFC heavyweight champion.
Put the show together.
I'm open.
You're open.
I think.
I'm hoping that Saturday,
September 10th I think I'm open.
So the Friday the ninth would be where we do the show.
Beautiful.
Let's do it,
I think to find something that's a crazy fight too.
That's an interesting fight because Alistair has been fighting very smart
lately,
man.
He's just put it together really nicely.
And his last few fights,
he's still a Jackson.
Yes.
He's still a Jackson's I think part time.
Pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it's still a Jackson's.
The thing about him again,
he was,
you know,
in pride and all that stuff.
He was the heavyweight champ of the champion and kickboxing,
you know,
that comes a time in your life when you put the pieces together and we're
starting to see it now.
Yup.
From Allister to Nate Diaz,
all these fighters that years ago they lost one,
you know,
didn't heal the,
who were even lose two,
he lost a clay,
Guido,
a Rafael dos Anjos broken jaw,
you know,
and look what he's gone on to do crazy.
And so it stay,
put it all together.
There's a,
it's like when a comedian gets a show,
you know this,
we're convenient together.
Show all the stars have to be aligned.
Right.
You know,
everything has to be in on everything just to get it on.
Right.
That's a complete,
everybody gets pilots every year.
But just to really get to that high level that you're talking about takes years.
You know,
maybe you maybe caught Dara when he went to court.
Darrow's Codero put it all together.
The jujitsu when the boxing or kickboxing put it all to it.
Definitely is a big part of,
it's a big part of it.
You know what else is a big part of it?
His strength and conditioning program.
He's one of those guys who trains under nick curse on you.
Do you know nick curse the curse on his?
Um,
he's one of the students of Marvin Marinovich,
you know the mob rent eviction Todd Marinovich story back.
Yeah.
And Marvin Marinovich was a world famous strength and conditioning coach with
like some seriously unconventional wild ideas that were very,
very effective.
And um,
he trained Bj Penn for a couple of camps and I'm nick curse on his,
one of his disciples and nick curse on handles though.
San Joe's and quite a few other guys on pro provident kickoff.
How'd he say his name was?
Lon providing the cough,
providing a cough.
Right.
I'm so high,
definitely shouldn't be doing this podcast right now,
providing the cough,
the Siberian rocky,
you know that guy I'm talking about.
He trains that guy too.
And Joe Schilling,
he's done some work with Joe.
He's a really good strength and conditioning guy and um,
cardy hero.
And,
uh,
the combination of like high level MMA high level and this radical strength and
conditioning program.
These guys do all these plyometrics.
It's all this box jumps.
Everything's like exploding and resting.
Everything's like very carefully monitored.
It's really interesting stuff man.
Do a lot of stuff with your feet.
That's one thing that uh,
he said that kind of blew my mind.
I was like,
yeah,
I didn't even think of that.
He goes,
I go,
what's the most important thing?
Like what do you work on a guy the most when you first started training him and
he's like their feet,
he's like foot strength is like one of the biggest like weaknesses that a lot of
fighters have.
Like their fetal get tired and so you don't push off,
you can't push off is hard.
He can't move as well.
Your,
your footwork starts to suck.
You can't explode in around.
And when you see a guy who's got like real good foot work and like this,
the ability to dive in and out and move very well and,
and fast,
you realize what a giant advantage that is.
Like,
Connor does it so well.
Leo Did it so well.
Wonderboy does it so well.
Oh Shit.
Joe Duffy,
Joe Duffy Banging on Mitch Clark.
very upset coming into this fight after losing a Dustin poray.
He's got a rear naked choke on them.
Clock taps.
Wow.
Beautiful Joe Duffys bad motherfucker.
He was a bad motherfucker.
But you know,
he rented to pour.
Yay.
When poor Yay had finally figured out that one 55 was the healthy weight class
for them.
So it was just killing himself,
making that one 45 limit.
He's a big boy.
You were standing next to Dustin Poirier.
He's a big dude.
He's a big dude to get down to 145 pounds.
These guys that do that man there.
Ooh,
what did he fight last?
He looked really fucking good.
Fuck Bobby Green knocked him out.
Really good.
Detailed am I should say and uh,
his standup looked excellent.
Excellent,
excellent.
He's so sharp and a real fluid was combinations and all the guys that Mcgregor
beat up,
those first two or three guys really have turned Holloway.
Max Holloway is a killer.
Right?
Oh Max Holloway fire.
Right.
He's the killer.
Receive as some web banging on a cage right now.
You know,
Dennis,
he was the only one that has a show.
What happened after Mcgregor?
But yeah.
Well Dennis Seaver,
it took a bad beating in that fight.
I remember watching that fight going all this is a,
it was a dentist's Seaver.
I think that first of all,
Connor is just better than them.
Qantas faster.
His bigger hits hard as fuck.
He's 30 years younger.
Yeah.
And the,
is this the miles Seavers hat?
Some wars inside the cage.
You know,
you'd go back and watch some,
a Seavers fights,
then think about the camps that he had and preparing for those fights.
Then think about the fucking wars did he must have had in the camps.
And you look at all that miles.
So it's like you see a guy like Conor beat a guy like Seaver and it just sort of
confirms what you already know.
Is it Conners the truth?
You know,
like he is that God damn good cause it was a beating,
you know,
it was just,
he and Seavers got an interesting style.
It's hard.
It's hard to beat him upstanding because Seaver throws hard shots and it's got
that weird karate style.
One kick is like,
uh,
yeah,
but he just was not,
when I first met John and I have gray hair.
Look at him now.
That's when he's like,
Obama,
you do these live shows freak the fuck out.
I'm looking at him going,
he had no fucking gray.
Hey,
he was the young kid two years ago.
What happened?
Props.
The Jon Anik for um,
getting that two oh nine tattoo.
That shit's hilarious.
You know when he did,
he made a,
he fucking said something like something silly about,
uh,
Nick Diaz that are Nate Diaz that if Nate Diaz won the fight with Conor,
he would get two oh nine tattooed on his arm.
Like first of all,
like you're,
you're probably not supposed to say that.
I don't think like especially about a guy that you have to commentate on.
And second of all,
I didn't agree with it at all.
Like I didn't agree with it at all.
Like stylistically,
I thought when those,
when they announced that match up,
I was like,
whoa.
Like Nate's a nightmare to people that don't know he's a nightmare.
If you don't know that guy's a nightmare,
we'll go watch that fight with Michael Johnson.
We beats up Michael Johnson standing,
you know,
go watch what he did to cowboy Cerrone's particularly in the first round.
Nate Diaz is a motherfucker will listen bro.
Oh Tattoos.
None.
Cause then triple you have to drink a bunk,
a bucket of or something.
It bucket of pests.
You'd forget about it in a couple of weeks.
He's going remember that Tattoo for the rest of that bucket of pistol lingo over
my head all week.
But Anik is a really good guy.
He's a good,
he's a real nice guy.
I really liked that guy.
I think he's a really good commentator too.
He's excellent at that job that he has and that Goldberg has,
that job is hard,
man.
That's,
it seems easy because they're good at it.
But if you had to do it or if I had to do it,
I would fail miserably.
I did it once a long time ago.
I failed miserably as me and Phil Baroni did an episode.
I was just terrible at that.
The,
my job is so much easier.
All I have to do as the fights are happening and I have to say what I think is
happening in the fight.
That's it.
The job of the Goldberg Guy or the Anak Guy or Michael Chavela or any of those
guys that more renown.
That's a very difficult job.
We go,
oh shit Duffy with the right hand.
Mitch is in trouble.
Well that dream and keep it together.
They're just a replay.
I was like,
what do you mean he had tapped,
didn't eat.
That's a beautiful angle of it.
That's a,
that's a quick beat down Joe Duffy working with for Rasa hobbies,
a big move to man.
That's a big move.
I know he had done some work with them before,
but,
um,
there's the,
there's like a couple of those guys,
like a Duke Roufus,
you know,
for us,
Matt Hume,
they just know so much for Ross's resume.
I want break down.
It's impressive as hell.
Yeah.
He was a kickboxer very good kickboxer and I'm nasty Jujitsu man.
Really Good Jujitsu.
I've seen him demonstrate some techniques and I've talked to some people that
roll with him.
Legit worldclass like very,
very good on the ground.
Like surprisingly good.
Yeah.
And just very smart,
very smart,
very good at breaking down fights.
Very Analytical Mind,
but very objective,
not ego based.
And he's,
you know,
he's strong and everything for us is as,
as a martial artist,
I think like,
I think you could say the same thing about Matt Hume.
Both those guys are elite in everything.
Like Matt Hume was an elite MMA fighter.
Mulatta people don't know he plot Pat Miletich back in the day.
This is before pat had become the UFC champion,
but pat was like a really well respected MMA fighter.
He was a real pioneer,
pat military.
It was and uh,
Matt Hume took them apart.
He blasted him,
he blasted him with a leg kicks and I believe he caught him with a knee and
broke his nose.
And it was real weird stoppage cause it was real quick fight and pat would have
fought through it but they stopped the fight because of a broken nose.
So like honestly,
I mean although Matt was having his way with them,
I mean it was just a series of exchanges.
We've all seen fights turn around where one guy's winning and he's dominating
and the other guy turns around and beat some.
But,
but Matt Hume,
my point is like,
did he beat,
even though there was a kind of a,
I just wanted to put it like it was kind of a funky stoppage because pat would
have definitely fought through it.
Like you'd have to kill pat military to get them to quit.
He's not quitting,
you know,
for a broken nose.
That didn't mean shit to him.
But the doctor just decided for whatever cause he knows like fucking nose go
home does it was like four or something like you,
you're believing like that gushing of I'd be fainting.
These guys have broken noses all the time and they fight through it now.
They fight through it all the time.
That fucking guy.
When when the Alvarez had the,
I like that.
I'm going home.
Listen,
I'm going with my come back next week on Friday.
We got to go look at this fucking what the fuck?
Broken nose.
I'm going to sit there and fight you to the death with a broken those shit.
Well Rory Macdonald's having a problem with his nose.
Apparently he broke it twice and training.
They were talking about it on a,
what is the ESPN shows or the uh,
Fox sports one chose e UFC tonight.
Is that what it is?
See tonight they were talking about the UFC tonight that he had gone through.
How the fuck do I not know that name?
I should probably know that.
Um,
that he had to go through a two broken noses in his camp.
So he broke his nose twice in camp preparing for that fine cause I think it was
really fucked up by Robbie Lawler and that Robbie Lawler fight was insane.
I got to fix my nose.
They would put two straws or my nose match,
but 30 years I was looking for a strong,
now they're putting the two strokes.
My knows what an invention they get to keep them there forever,
for a week.
So I used the surgery Monday and then for a weekend,
two straws on my phone and then they pull the straws out and they both estrozen.
I had a splint in my nose.
It's interesting man because
it kind of changed the shape of my nose a little bit.
Like it made my inside.
There was so much they cut out in like the the,
they have these things called turbinates,
you know there's things out there they get in the way too.
They cut those out and he said they just pulled out just giant chunks of scar
tissue that had calcified.
There was just no breathing or that stupid notes.
You're going to love it,
Joey.
Once you get it done,
all my God,
you're going to feel so good.
Read of your nose gets done.
The right side is done.
I must have to have that side would blow killed.
But when that shit,
all I could see is that Bechtel I could see is that doctor or Monday,
like the dentist when the cleaning a cavity and she's got the goggles and I'm in
coke rocks.
They hit me in the face and fucking aluminum foils.
Pubic cares and God knows what else I snot a cheat rock,
whatever the fuck comes off that ceiling and carpets and Kat,
I put all that shit cause sometimes you drop a coke rock on the floor listening
to 400 more than that.
Coke rock's going down.
I don't give a fuck what's on the floor,
Dale thumbtacks led it all goes again.
Those you deal with it in the morning and the morning he'll come out,
something will be there.
Fuck ass unfucking beliefs.
Have you spilled a little bit on a hardwood floor?
Would you get down on that floor and sniff it right off for a fucking put my
finger and whatever else stuck to my finger.
We might say it was a little coke.
Rockman had limped around and the sheet rock,
whatever else was on that finger went in my fucking nose.
It some water and I just held it up there to melted and whatever happened to
happen.
Oh my God.
It's just crazy.
That's just crazy.
And the doctor's name is doctor line,
Yeah.
I don't know if it's a joke.
The doctor's fiction.
He knows his doctor line doc.
The line.
That's the fucking knows.
Doctor.
See this one of those things where it just makes you feel like we're not living
in reality.
This is it,
doctor line.
We're not.
When he gave me the reference,
I fucking died.
My family doctor,
I go,
you serious?
His name is doctor line.
This can't be real joy to movie.
It's a fucking day.
We're living in a moving this Jon Jones Shit.
Joey Diaz.
How disappointed.
Real disappointed.
I'm like a 10.
I was at 10 out of all like fight cancellation,
disappointments.
That was heartbreaking to call.
I could fucking night nine o'clock at night.
I found that
I found out about Jamie.
Jamie texted it to me and I was just heartbroken.
I don't know,
I just couldn't believe it.
It was like,
oh no,
I couldn't believe it.
It's not drugs.
Um,
I don't know what it is.
It's not because he's been tested by the probation department.
Well how often they test them every two weeks.
Maybe once a month.
What if he was doing something that well who the fuck knows?
So this is just speculation,
but just from what I understand,
I don't think they pull
you off a card if you were doing pot.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if he tested positive for marijuana this far out cause it was in June,
I do not think they would pull them off the card.
He tested positive once before.
Before for what?
Yes,
against calling me way before.
But what I'm saying is I don't think it's that,
no,
I think it's a ped.
Oh God.
That's what I think it is now.
What's a pee Dee?
Exactly.
Performance enhancing drug,
which could be,
he could be an accident.
It's in,
it's had been an accident many times.
Tim Means,
um,
it was the most recent example.
I mean he told them straight up,
this is all I took.
They went to the fucking store,
bought it off the shelf,
opened it up,
tested it.
He had that shit in it.
So this is these people,
we've said it time and time again folks.
There's people that are selling these things in vitamin stores and these muscle
building things.
And there's some people that are,
you know,
it might say that it has the ingredients on the list,
which are all things that have been shown to help build your body up.
But they throw other stuff in there too.
They just do,
they want their stuff to work.
So sometimes they make these things and they just put steroids in them.
Like you could go to a fucking GNC or a vitamin Shoppe and you can go and buy
steroids like legit steroids.
Like they will make you fucking big like steroids.
We used to keep catching them not as good as the best of the best steroids,
but at times there were,
I've talked about it before.
There was this stuff called Mag 10 that you could get.
It was so strong.
It was crazy how strong it was.
You just reject jacked.
There's so much of that stuff.
There's so many of those things out there and they just keep making them and
then they catch them and then they have to change the name and they come back.
That's how they do with those boner pills to those boner pills are filled with
like steroids and fucking Viagara like we need to do an Ana test of,
of boner pills.
We needed just like see,
go by whatever red bands taken and take it to a lab and just find out.
Exactly.
You buy those over the counter,
not even over the counter.
It's like you buy my gas stations only.
It's like regular stores aren't going to sell those rhino pills.
You have to buy them in the shittiest.
I apparently,
according to red band,
I haven't taken them.
They destroy it.
They turn it into a fucking cock heating Zombie,
your,
your Dick just becomes a monster.
You,
Dick,
just a,
something happens to it.
It just gets so hard that you can't believe it.
You're,
you're,
you're filled with lust and passion.
People talk about it like they're crazed.
I'm like,
you're taking math.
They're taking meth mixed with my Viagra.
Like someone's dosing them up with some ridiculously high levels of speed and
probably some steroids and some math and some Viagra just I was out of,
they don't have to tell you what's in there.
While I was out of,
I was out of that him of course chocolate.
I didn't have enough
chance to send the kid in the email,
get it.
So I just went to the store and I asked to get,
I just want pro,
I didn't want to spend the $94 for the way cause I didn't want to haul all that
protein powder.
So I went through the one on Lankershim and he goes,
do you take the preworkout shit?
And I don't take my,
I take the fucking quadriceps.
I didn't tell him that,
but I take the,
I take like half of the shroom tech.
I don't want to have a fucking heart attack.
I think half of those fucking shoot tax.
Sometimes you're in the middle of the class and you're gasping for air because
so much air is coming into you and my body can't take it.
It's too much fucking ass sometimes.
Like you're like,
fuck this is too much.
So I just went there,
went there,
the guy goes,
take this.
It's like a drink before the fucking,
uh,
before you work out again.
I had it in the bag and I drove and I get done.
I go,
let me just try it.
I tried half of it.
I did the class,
but on the way home I had the wildest fucking harder.
I had to go home,
take a shower and jerk off in the fucking shower because the Harlem,
it was real.
Momma wasn't on,
nobody was around.
I mean it was fucking evil.
And even after I jerked off,
it stayed hard.
Dod and the shower.
I was like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
I got to save this shit and drink it with Mama's around these things by hand.
The one sentence thing,
then I got scared because after I jerked off,
like an hour later,
my heart side haven't popped it.
Then I'll put the shit enough with this,
but I don't do anything.
Listen,
I've never been a proponent,
is that the word to fucking read book?
Because when I was shooting a movie,
once I was up on nights,
you don't blow and I fucking drank three of those red bulls and I fell asleep.
So I said,
fuck it.
That's not then that shit.
That shit don't work.
I drank three of those red bulls and was not done the set.
So those things don't fucking work.
So I've never been really been any energy drink.
I grew up without energy drinks.
You'd expect me to like energy drinks.
I hate all that shit.
I don't believe it.
When I was a beginning comment,
I used to take no dogs to drive all night.
That was horrible.
That stuff's nasty.
Just when I would drink it with mountain dude really goes deep and smoke a
joint.
You drive all night like this,
look like that all night and then you pull over.
He didn't take a nap and I would take a nap at the car cause it was the winter.
Like in those days I had to drive,
I would have to do the late show as a feature and then drive back to boulder
overnight from Boise,
Idaho or wherever the fuck I was at billings,
Montana.
So I would drive all night to get pick to pick up the baby.
In those days I'd have to do whatever the fuck I had to do.
One Night Jamie had pulled the car over and it was freezing out and left the car
around and I fell asleep.
And when I woke up I thought I lost control of the car.
You have no idea what happens to your heart.
Oh my God.
When you fall asleep and then wake up and I had to have the right turn and I saw
all the snow and I was like,
oh,
oh.
And you grabbed the steering wheel when you put the brake on and be like,
I'm not even fucking moving.
Oh my God.
So those no dozes with mountain dew.
It all my boy,
there you go.
Alan Gel ban just about to step
into the octagon right now.
Yeah.
Great Dude.
Very sweet.
Love.
He says hello.
He's the one,
uh,
Eddie.
As long as students,
I've known that kid forever.
He's awesome.
It's always been awesome.
Great guy to train with.
Super Cool.
And he's,
he's been doing really well.
And you have c except the Einstein fight,
you know?
But,
um,
uh,
that guy two men off is a beast,
man.
Albert Tumen off.
It's just so technical,
his striking.
It's just so good.
And uh,
what we gotta do that Raphael Cordeiro has,
has,
has always fucked up,
doesn't look like much of a fighter.
He got,
I poke last time twice and he just knocked the mother fucker out.
Baru.
Shh.
Oh,
didn't you know,
but I like him too.
I like Raphael [inaudible] is a really good Jujitsu player too,
man.
She is Jujitsu.
No,
his kickboxing has come a long way with Cordura.
You know,
he's,
he's kickbox is really good now.
It's excellent.
But uh,
his Jujitsu's now he's designing,
he keeps his guard down like his hands low,
which always sometimes,
yeah.
But Codero is called Dero so I trust they're up to something.
So it's none of my business going,
what the fuck that you know,
his diaries of very smart guy,
very smart guy.
And uh,
he's hard worker and he'll get better.
You know,
I mean,
he,
right now he's,
he's cracking into that top 10 realm.
You know,
he's a,
he's a very,
very good fighter.
Some brother had a setback in the,
she has a fight.
[inaudible] Michael Kia choked him.
But Kiyosaki,
I'm telling you,
man,
Michael Casaa has nasty back control.
I watch my kids the way takes backs and the weight clamps down.
He's got a super like,
very tight game.
Some guys just have a technique like you remember Cody,
Mckinsey had that fucking guillotine of death.
Like if Mckenzie caught you in that guillotine,
man,
he's putting dude's asleep and you look at him,
not a physical specimen,
you know,
just looks like a regular dude.
He's not athletically gifted.
He just had this one technique,
razor sharp,
razor sharp and for,
okay,
it's four minutes and 50 seconds right now in round number one.
So that's the timestamp.
46,
45,
44 43 you got it.
Um,
but,
uh,
chaos has got that with his back mountain man.
He gets that back mount on dudes.
That rear naked choke is a strong position for him.
Alan Joe Ban looking very light on his feet here.
Listen,
man,
once you get the elite level,
you have to be very intelligent as a fighter.
He,
there's no other way to improve.
No higher level.
No,
no,
no.
You're not a bar brawl with no more that goes in there with,
I'm going to punch him in the mouth mentality.
Yeah.
You figured out how to win the war.
You train accordingly.
I mean those guys,
uh,
and at Jujitsu,
oh shit,
they left hand Joe Ban that Jujitsu makes you so analytical when you were a high
level black belt.
It makes you think so much differently and you know,
just growing and kicks and punches,
you know,
you have to think so much quickly when you roll with those high level black
belts game over.
I mean it's just a,
yeah,
Joe bands here in full guard.
Um,
I would like to see him pass.
I don't like this.
Yeah,
see and he got swept and now he's stuck in a standing gear team but only one arm
in.
I don't ever like it when dudes lay in the guard.
I just think if you're on top and you're in the guard,
you should at least attempt to pass because if you can pass and get to a
dominant position,
you,
you established that you have the better ground game.
Right.
And then you also have the opportunity to try to set some stuff up for real and
you force someone to be completely defensive because someone in the guard is
still partially offensive.
They can still catch you.
When you get a guy inside control,
you're almost a hundred percent offensive and he's almost a hundred percent
defensive is only like a couple of things you could do from the bottom like with
elbows and maybe you can catch up Kamora if the guy's not paying attention.
But for the most part when you're in the guard,
like look,
we were talking about with Verdomme,
there's still guys that could fuck you up from there.
Brian Ortega,
he will fuck you up from inside.
It's guard laying.
That dude's guard.
Good luck.
That guy will fuck people up in that guard.
I just think sometimes do to try and play it safe.
You know they get a guy down in there inside of his guard and they just say hi,
let me just throw some punches here and see what's up.
And they just kind of cancel each other out.
So what you're saying is if you're in the closed God,
get the fuck out of him.
Yeah.
Don't get,
first of all I don't like fall into it and obviously easier said than done.
Right.
But don't choose to fall into it.
Treat it like it's a dangerous place.
Get out of there for on everybody.
Even on guys that may be the guards,
not that good.
Pretended is treat everybody the same way.
Get the fuck oh head check.
Oh that was brutal.
This dude's done.
If this guy survives as he is a fucking monster.
Oh elbows.
Oh
Wow.
This dude is gutting it out.
He has gotten it out,
man.
Come on,
let's do this shit.
Allah.
Muhammad is tough as he's fuck man.
He is tough as fuck cause he is.
He is not giving up at all man.
Giving up his back.
Don't give up your back.
Oh needed a body.
Those knees against the fence or brutality man leaves the body against the
fence.
They were rough like when Anderson got chill son,
that one.
Ooh,
nice slice pass.
Keep going
Mama guys,
a motherfucker dude to survive that.
He's getting back up to his feet.
Look at this shit and he rolls ban on top.
Awesome.
Oh we went crazy with the flying punch.
Japan's wrestling looks pretty good too,
man.
Good defense here.
But it's Muhammad guy looks very strong.
I think Joe Band,
those guys work out with the kickboxing somewhere in north Hollywood.
Really?
So Saxons?
Yes.
Yeah.
That school up north,
I would think that was in Van Nuys,
Van Nuys,
wherever.
Uh,
uh,
all the was used to be.
Oh yeah,
that's cool.
There.
I think one of the kids that goes to daycare trains without ms kid goes,
oh okay.
He always tells me that's what,
yeah,
that sax on a Jim is one of the best gyms around in this,
uh,
in this city for uh,
for kickboxing.
A lot of guys out of their fight in local competitions,
he's got guys in glory and he's got Alan and a bunch of other guys,
but very high risk,
highly respected gym.
Damn Muhammad's bad motherfucker.
Okay.
I do.
It's tough cause he got clanged he got lefthanded on the point of Chan.
I mean that's a nice sort of hooking lefthand and then call anger.
He got double claimed,
he got claimed with the Shin and then climbed the punch after it Dank.
That's a boom,
boom.
I guy is tough as fuck.
Nice.
So here's something that happens in exchange is like that sometimes when a dude
hurt to guy and then unloads on him trying to finish them but can't finish them.
Now I'm not a guy like Alan because Alan is pretty experienced.
I don't think he emptied his gas tank,
but guys have empty their fucking gas tank trying to take a guy out and then had
to coast for the remaining second and third round.
Like some guys they,
they've,
they're notorious for that.
Like they open up on you and if it,
like I'm looking at Allen right now,
he looks really tired and some guys do that.
They'll open up with that first round and they think they got a guy hurt.
But if the guy can survive,
they've blown a lot of gas and a lot of adrenaline too cause they got emotional.
They just went crazy after Ya.
And then when it's,
when it doesn't happen and the guy survived and he's still there,
there's just like a mind fuck going on.
Like oh no.
Did I empty my gas tank?
Was the big guy against that Brock and Adam was born Shane motherfucking card.
Yeah,
for sure.
A couple of the five.
And I didn't understand what he was saying at first.
If they gassed in the first round,
your arms get tired.
I didn't understand that concept,
but I saw it a couple times and I was like,
ah,
well Shane was a monster dude.
I mean,
he had just ridiculous punching power and he was,
uh,
just far more skillful,
at the time,
at least.
Then Brock was standing when Shane was a really good striker standing up his,
uh,
his punches were short and he had mad confidence in them.
Like he would slug it out with anybody.
And one of the best examples of that when he fought Gabriel Gonzaga,
Gonzaga brokage snows like Gonzaga had him hurt.
He broke his nose and staggered them.
And then when Gonzaga moved in for the kill,
Shayne hit him with six inches of death.
Just this soup,
that giant cinder block and the end of is impossibly thick arms.
And he just punched through Gonzaga his head.
It was ridiculous.
He has this,
he's like short punches that he hit Frank Mir with.
He tied up Frank Mir,
he got him in like a collar tie or something like that.
I forget what to do or maybe over hooked him.
I forget what he did to control his body but then he'd just upper cut it the
fuck out of him and it was just brutal.
The power and the speed and the fucking leverage of these shots.
I was like just St Shankar was one of the scariest guys have punch you maybe
ever Shane Carmen and corks on you.
Like I've watched that guy knock out a lot of dudes and there's something about
him in particular like his physical size and you know until his body started
having serious problems because of all his football career and you know,
just years of combat sports training his,
you know,
his body was giving him real,
real big problems.
Now what back you feel in the octagon when your arms get like that?
They just got heavy acid fills your arms.
You'd have to talk to them obviously,
cause I've never fought in the octagon.
But like there's an ampule of boxers.
Yeah,
sure.
This type of training happened.
A boxers where they get all adrenaline dumps.
The adrenaline dumps are so real.
But there's also a thing about MMA versus boxing.
Five minutes is a long fucking time.
It's a long time and you can't sprint for five minutes.
No one can.
And so with a guy like Joe ban,
like did he sprint there?
That's the question.
Did he sprint?
Did he go all out and then couldn't go any further?
And then had a minute 40 left in the round and Muhammad survives and Muhammad
feels that he feels that Joe Bam,
I had a fucked up and empty this gas tank.
Now he's got Jo Bang up against the cage.
Joe Bands moving around,
he looks a little slower.
You know,
it gets,
it gets interesting because that's,
that's a famous quote.
Um,
I think someone else said it,
but shale,
shale son is the one that told it to me.
Um,
he said that if you try to take a guy out in the first round but don't,
you're most certainly lose a decision
or you're more likely to lose a decision.
Like you try to win the fight by knockout or don't win the fight at all because
you're not going to have the gas to go three rounds.
Now,
is there anything you could do and your strength and conditioning program to
avoid that
you can recover faster with the most efficient training and get getting yourself
in the very best peak shape you can recover faster?
You know,
the question is,
okay,
is a guy like Alan or is this gentleman Mohammed?
Are these guys in their optimum physical shape?
Well,
you don't really know.
They're there obviously in fantastic shape there obviously elite athletes,
but are they at their best?
I mean if they,
if he was with a mark Marinovich or someone along those lines,
I mean who knows what a guy like that could do on strength and conditioning
level.
And so then it becomes a matter of how important is the strength and
conditioning.
See that's where guys like Marinovich and like even nick curse on a lot of these
guys,
they differ from a lot of the pack.
They think it's the most important thing.
And I think he's right.
I think once you already learned how to fight,
then it's almost less important to do spend all the time boxing and sparring and
almost more important to do drills and do mad strength and conditioning work.
Cause I think you'd take less off your body,
your,
you already know how to fight me.
Alan Gel band knows how to fucking fight and this is not going to be a surprise
for him.
How much fight training does he need to do versus conditioning training because
if he's in the same position here in this fight,
but had less time in camp hitting,
you know,
uh,
hitting sparring partners but more time doing plyometrics and was much fresher
and felt better and this round that the argument is like,
you're better off having the most fit vehicle to do combat with.
Like your mind already knows how to go do combat,
right?
You're gonna know how to kick.
You already know how to punch your gonna know how to choke dudes.
You're not gonna get much better at that in six weeks.
But here's what you can get better.
At six weeks,
you could ramp your cardio up to some fucking ungodly levels.
So the question becomes,
should you invest all your time doing that or shooting you,
invest your time and fight training.
And it's the great debate.
Now we had the discussion about Robbie Lawler,
the Robbie Lawler's training camps consist of wrestling and hitting the patch
used to use as far as now in bars.
I don't think it's a coincidence that the time that he's backs barring is also
the time when he went on this unbelievably successful run in the UFC and it's
now the welterweight champ.
I don't think you can get away with not sparring.
I don't,
but some people do.
And some people think that,
uh,
you,
you don't need to spar at all.
Are you spar very little.
And most of what you do is,
I mean,
that works for them.
Some people think that sparring is the most important thing.
Eddie Alvarez when 150 rounds to prepare for Dos Anjos and I'm sure Eddie
Alvarez does everything else.
I'm sure he does strength and conditioning.
I know he does a lot of pad work.
I know he does everything.
He's an animal.
He leaves no stone unturned.
Right.
But that's a lot of spartan,
right?
Some guys don't like spar much at all.
Some guys spar very little maybe spa real light spot like once a week.
And they saved themselves.
I mean it's,
everybody's got their own method to prepare.
But guys like curse on and I guess it's Marinovich is um,
this is there a,
there a school of thought was like for a guy like Bj,
Bj Penn,
the Marinovich took Bj Penn to its highest heights.
Like when,
when they were training together.
Bj hated the training,
but God damn was the unstoppable inside the octagon.
That was the fiend dom beanie.
Bj Penn.
That was the real prodigy when Bj Penn was lightweight champion.
Like when he'd destroyed Sean Sherk when he destroyed Diego Sanchez.
God Damn Bj was good for this brief time.
That's,
you know,
a few funds is cardio was a suspect at all at all with them at all with them.
But the training is just unbearable.
He beat,
Bj did an interview about it.
We're just talking about it.
We couldn't even hold his baby in his arms,
man.
He would get home at night and he couldn't hold his baby.
His arms were too tired.
If they break you,
they're all about physical conditioning.
I mean Marinovich is a fucking mad scientist,
man.
I'm giggling because Monday was 4th of July and maybe asshole decides to go to
the Drusen.
Mr. Crane goes,
fuck it.
There's no teacher Dick Today.
Just seven minute rounds.
I didn't know this.
I can't hear.
I'm deaf.
I hear him.
He puts the clock and you have to pick your sparring partner.
Girl picks me.
She fucks me up.
Right?
Cause she's about a buck tag.
This girl with a tattoo over eyebrow.
So I know I'm in for fucking dog fight with this girl.
She can't pull me down and she can't move me around.
But she's taking my back,
Joe Rogan.
I'm dying and I'm huffing and puffing.
I looked up this three 50 left on the clock,
three minutes and 30 minutes left.
I thought I was going to fucking die.
He made us do that seven times at the end.
I just looked at them,
Joe and I was like,
Jesus Christ,
I don't know how you high level motherfuckers do this.
Oh yeah.
I couldn't.
I couldn't even walk there at night.
My legs were killing me,
but I will tell you what I've been doing over that,
Joe.
That's helped me a lot and it's right what you're saying,
that tactical fitness again,
the 30 minute class after the Jujitsu class and it's just little exercises that
you don't think much of,
but next thing you know,
Shit's pouring out of you.
How you're doing it with that kettle Jitsu guy.
The guy on Instagram?
No,
no,
no.
He's my buddy Joey Alvarado.
Good guy.
He's got a good Instagram page.
He really wants to draw Alvarado videos have really does good kettlebell
exercises.
Yeah,
he really does.
At six 30 in the morning and dog,
and he's saying he's a Jujitsu player to black belt Machado.
Black power.
There you go.
That makes sense.
Because he had real good exercises,
grappling for grappling for Jujitsu.
That shift starts at five 30 in the morning with him.
That's an animal man.
Five 30 kettlebells,
SixThirty Jujitsu,
then it closes down until nine.
Then they start the attack fit than they do no gate than they do drills.
Then they do the regular Jujitsu and there's people that stay there from nine to
one.
Joe Rogan,
Jesus Christ.
This is dude.
Uh,
I'm friends with Jocko Willink.
He's a former navy seal and now does like,
um,
he does like seminars for businesses and stuff like that.
Teaches them how to motivate and lead groups.
This motherfucker such a savage that every morning he takes a photo of his watch
when he gets up to work out.
He works out every morning at four 30,
so take hates but,
but his Instagram is filled with these pictures of his watch at four 30.
And you want to,
you want to see some shit that makes you feel lazy.
Fall that guys' Instagram every fucking day.
Four,
four 30 all caps get after it and he's doing fucking dead lifts and squats and
fucking throwing kettle bells around and doing dibs early morning guy.
Oh No,
not at all.
As you grow weights around,
um,
sometimes I love it.
Well I do weird shit.
There's Jockos look at it.
We get his fucking Instagram page is all four 13.
Oh,
that guy is Yay trains a dean lister.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know who that is.
Legit,
legit.
Top level black belt too.
I mean,
I know for a fact that he goes to war with lister and lister is one of the best
in the fucking world.
I mean,
and he's got a podcast to that Jocko.
Jocko podcast.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I convinced him to do it after doing the podcast with him here to Allen's in
trouble.
He's in trouble.
He's taken some hard shots here.
He's getting roughed up.
That upper cut there.
I think what we're talking about might have happened and he talks to you.
You could see them on the ground.
He was tired.
Yeah,
I saw him after the first round.
Oh,
he got spinning back fist.
He's all right there.
They went to a decision.
I wonder who won.
Well,
he won this round.
I think a while back to Allen was the first two.
So that guy's a tough,
tough motherfucker.
You congrats to him.
We even went on where?
Loose garments.
He was 12 and old going into this.
I don't think they really,
I get this his first UFC fight or not?
I don't think so.
I feel like he's had one,
but God damn,
I'm impressed with him man.
Yup.
This is his first one.
Yeah,
cause he didn't have a picture of them.
Didn't even have a fucking picture of him.
He's really good,
bad.
He's really good.
He's tough as shit too.
I mean he,
he got,
oh look at that right hand.
That's nice and clean.
He got clanger it in that first round man.
You can never forget that.
He got clanger twice.
He was in real trouble.
That guy gutted through that weather the storm and started putting it on him
beginning in sometime in the second round
because it has nice combinations.
Sometimes I'm up at four 30 I drink a glass of water with ice in it to get
everything going and I make it a little coffee.
I make an almond smoothie and it's like five 45 and I go,
maybe I go to the six 30 Jujitsu class.
Whoa,
fuck you tax.
Most heart attacks out between 6:00 AM and 12 bitch.
Do they?
I don't do a jumping Jack Til 12 you me not to.
And now they're saying if he asked of you older than 50 they happen between a
midnight.
You know between men,
they want you to take a baby aspirin and drink a glass of water.
No pissing on night.
You know,
I don't.
I go on a fucking drought after six so I could sleep fucking nine hours straight
without pissing.
Now they want you to drink a big glass of water at midnight before you fucking
go to bed.
Yeah.
That's not good for your sleep patterns.
No,
but that's what they said.
You need to do.
Why do you need to do that?
Check out the journal over this mad one of those things.
Yeah.
So now they're saying that a baby aspirin,
the glass,
you guess,
give me guess who else and Joe Ban.
But
282729282927
Allen Joe Band.
But he better get on his knees and thank the Lord you better get on his knees
and thank the Lord and Satan and whoever else.
Well,
cause he knows he was getting hit at the end and he knows he's gonna walk out
and go,
Jesus,
I was running on ag.
Uh,
yeah,
he was in trouble.
Alan Jaeger band.
Just given that dude.
Perhaps that's what a Nice Guy Alan Jobe ban is.
No,
but me coming here and taking them out like that.
I belong in the top 10,
top 15 Joel silver.
They don't want you.
I need to topic.
Do you find that guys?
Yeah,
he should have used better wording.
I mean I see what he's trying to do,
but he didn't say took him out cause he didn't take that dude out.
Mean he heard him in the first round,
number one my hand in the second round.
Clangor
well,
I'll put slowed down a lot.
I couldn't really throw any left hands after that song was just kind of trying
to survive with my right hand and my kids.
What was the mentality in that boat and blowing around the rally too little too
late though.
You don't.
My coaches led me through it with my coach and said,
give me five good minutes.
You don't need to let him just set up the kids,
set up everything else.
So Alan Jobe and broke his hand that second round.
People are listening to this probably like what happened to them?
Did they go away?
Sorry.
We're listening to and that's a problem with actually no one to do it.
And being friends with a dude and then uh,
doing commentary on his fights and watching him fight.
It's like,
I just know him.
Such a nice dude.
So what's the earliest you could work out?
My brother,
I'll get up sometimes before the dawn and work out what it says.
So I don't know.
Sometimes I get up to pee,
right.
It might be like five o'clock in the morning and I just as like a little mental
exercise.
I said I'm just going to go work out and then just forced myself to go workout.
Don't worry for no food,
no nothing.
Straight up.
Get some water,
bad breath going there.
And how long have you is a full or is it just to get the blood going?
It depends,
you know,
but it's always got to be something hard to do.
Powerful Robbie Lawler.
Usually it's,
you know,
I'll do some chin ups.
I'll do some kettlebell work.
Just do like 40 minutes,
maybe more,
maybe an hour.
And you'd go back to the bedroom to sleep.
Maybe the Hogan fucking snow.
Sometimes I stay up.
I don't know man.
Sometimes I like to go up,
get up early rather because,
uh,
I like to go outside,
like when everything's coming on,
there's something weird about like seeing,
seeing people wake up,
sort of like seeing people leave the houses and seeing,
seeing the hustle and bustle as they're starting to get ready to go to work.
You know,
you can,
you can actually kind of see it in the distance all spread out.
When you're,
you get up in the morning and go sit outside on your porch or something like
that and look around.
Just something about,
uh,
it just makes you really recognized the strange cycle,
strange cycle that we do every night.
Sleep in her eyes and sleep and rise and get caught up in the momentum and keep
doing the same thing over and over again.
Try and figure out what the fuck you're doing.
Well,
sometimes when you watch other people doing it,
you kind of realize it's like,
oh,
this is like a weird,
we're like pattern things we have,
we follow patterns like humans,
uh,
on a whole,
we love to follow patterns.
We follow the same patterns over and over and over and over again.
Same routes to work.
Same Bullshit you're dealing with at the office.
You know,
day in,
day out,
day out.
When you watch people do it.
Like when you get up early,
if you don't have to go somewhere and you watch the city come alive,
it's like almost like you get to see the fucking work behind the curtain before
the play plays out.
So you get to see like,
oh,
this is,
this is weird.
It was the last time you got up for work a week in a row.
I can fit back.
Yeah.
That was the last time I had a job.
Job,
job,
job.
I hated those homes.
You know?
I came from a home boy.
The mornings would,
there wasn't much action.
I got up,
I made my own fucking cereal.
I took a shower,
I dress myself on the way out.
I said,
mom,
see you later.
That's it.
But then you went to people's homes who it was heavy duty.
They were going to work and I would sit there and go,
fuck this shit.
I hate that action in the morning that where's my toothbrush?
Where's my fucking shirt?
You know,
for people yelling,
everybody get out of the fucking back and you're go to the bathroom.
Smells like 10 shifts.
You know?
You're like,
fuck this,
you know.
So I swore to God if I ever had a family,
I don't want that early morning fucking riff Raff.
Yeah.
I like,
she's got riff Raff in the morning and this drama with her in the morning,
but not really.
She's three and a half now.
She wakes up,
she puts the TV on,
she gets her own truck with milk.
I get up.
I don't give it.
Why you gotta make it fun?
I got to shake it with it through the whole fucking thing.
But besides that,
she leaves me the fuck alone.
There's no drama.
I don't like that early morning drama.
Right.
Once I hit life.
Okay,
that's drowning because I don't want to know what you're saying.
My house running out the door.
I don't want that shit.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
I checked.
People relax.
I walk up.
I liked that slow.
Yeah.
I go to,
it's really weird.
I appreciate the fives in the mornings.
I appreciate the six in the mornings.
I love going outside and smoking and watching and,
but I also appreciate two in the morning.
Sometimes I get back to the valley.
I just sit on my balcony and look out and I go,
Jesus Christ,
it's a fucking nothing.
That's it.
We're in space.
Yeah,
this is it.
I'm in space.
It's me and that fucking mood and those three stars around it.
I think you need a little place where you can go.
Occasionally.
We don't hear anybody.
Nobody's talking.
We can just look up,
just look up by herself.
I think we all need that.
We missed that and that's a really interesting
aspect of civil as ancient that as we become more and more dependent upon
technology,
more and more into lights,
we were less and less aware of the fact that we're in space.
It's a lot.
It's all happening together.
It's like the technology that's going to take people past where we are now to
some strange new world and the next decade or a hundred years or whenever the
next fucking crazy invention comes out.
You know,
I like getting up at five,
but I don't turn the TV on.
I don't check Twitter.
That's good.
I look,
I charge my phone in the living room and I look at it to see if somebody called
with an emergency.
Unless I see ms call Miss [inaudible].
I put the phone down for two hours.
I don't do Dick in the morning.
I have a notebook in front of me.
I drink coffee.
After about 30 minutes I go smoke some pot and really kick it up and maybe even
nicotine gum and get the party really started.
I was,
I just drained.
What's in your coconut?
Maybe the,
I think about the night before.
I didn't tape that set last night,
but I said one thing onstage that I liked and I'll write that down.
I have a page of just shit.
I sat on stage and I before then it's got to going anywhere and you liked the
nicotine gum,
gives you a little stimulant is up in the morning with coffee.
Look at this guy.
He keeps losing more and more weight.
Was he fighting that one on one 45 and he's fighting on Saturday so he's in the
weight cutting already.
She's dehydrated there.
You could fucking towel.
She's five 45 I think he's fighting 45 wait a minute.
Who's he fighting this weekend?
Jim Miller.
No,
I think he's felt 50 fellows.
Five talking about me.
Oh,
that's right.
Miller's fighting go on me.
That's the best.
Best under the under the under card of all fucking time I think to Django was
fighting 55 I think 45 was too much for him.
Yeah.
He looks 45
right now.
I'm 55
yeah,
one 55 but he's the kind of guy that even at 55 is going to cut weight.
He's going to get a little bigger and dropped down.
Who was he fighting again?
Joe Loans on.
That's right.
I was going to be a while.
That's fine.
Joe Lozan has been some Goddamn wars over the last few years.
What was it that look at that early prelim.
Tremendous sell.
That's incredible.
That's an incredible deal.
He's still supposed to fight someone.
Yup.
Any idea who it could be?
Do you think?
I'm going to tell you,
you know you were fucking reporter.
I don't know what
fucking fights his shit.
He can't fight twice in,
I know a few things.
I know a few things,
but I can't talk about them.
I know a few things about other things.
I know some things I can say nothing if you don't know nothing.
I don't know.
I don't see nothing.
I tell you what,
this Jon Jones thing like literally broke my heart.
I mean,
when you say,
when you said it to me,
it was like a distant relative.
Died.
Not like a close one,
but like,
oh,
aunt sue,
fuck.
I remember her like a,
like a relative that haven't seen since I was 15.
Choose different substances that whatever.
And they're not just one substance to,
oh yeah,
that's what you're reading.
Which,
which website?
Um,
where I lost that car that might pull it off.
I,
how would I have left up is what he said about it.
And it was like,
oh,
substance he couldn't pronounce.
Okay.
But I haven't,
well that's not entirely what I hear.
I can pronounce both of the substances that I heard.
Jamie,
how many do you want?
Let's see.
What are you doing now?
All these stars at death
number 200 Jesus career.
How many you want to just chill in this?
You just say 200 years through two of when your mouth,
you all to get the party's car.
Oh my God.
How are you doing that?
How can you do that?
How has your body hold up?
I'm a savage this and CBD oil.
I got the glue that keeps the bones together.
You know what I'm saying?
This is a must.
Your inflammation level must be zero.
If pot is anti-inflammatory,
let's apparently it is your inflammation level.
Does she think the oil,
I'm getting this 51% this honey off.
Wow.
Let me tell you some three,
four drops in the morning.
I do it after the almond shake.
I let the almond shake leave my mouth when I put that thing on that hold it for
60 seconds.
There's times I go home,
I'm going to hold fat.
Fuck man.
I go home.
I sparked two times.
I'm done.
I go home.
I could feel my legs that fucking,
they feel like they're swollen.
I do a Tylenol instead of fame and I do three or four of those drops baby,
and the next day I'm ready to rock again.
Wow.
You know,
I don't know exactly what the CBD oil,
every time I look up benefits,
they tell one more.
You read now and it prevents dementia.
You know,
you read all these fucking things.
They'd been hiding this shit.
David Hyde and this shift from America,
man.
Well it's be because pot's been illegal.
They haven't been able to give people CBD oil.
And you mean it has low levels of THC?
You'll test positive for THC with a lot of it.
No,
but now it's legal in 50 states and you could smell it so it's got an OT.
The only reason why that's going on is because they take,
you don't catch positiveness saying,
well,
they must be way better at it now.
Yeah,
no,
now they're really getting it down.
But he was,
it's an element of marijuana.
I mean,
absolutely.
It's got to be.
Yeah.
They can make strains that are higher in CBD oil.
I mean,
maybe they figured out a way to extract CBD oil a hundred percent pure where
there's no residue of THC and then they add a little THC to it because
counterbalanced with the THC,
that's what gets everything that's a worse on those tumors that come to,
you know,
so that CBD oil is supposed to be amazing for inflammation though.
Yeah.
That's um,
that's a real unfortunate thing that they did that they kept us illegal for so
long.
It's just,
it helped a few people profit and it fucked a lot of people over.
It fucked a lot of people over.
Not just,
not just because people got locked up in jail,
but because people got the wrong impression of an awesome plant.
The really crazy thing was that I was never familiar with holistic medicine
until I moved to boulder and I thought these people were fucking quacks.
Like they talked to me like God,
but then you start paying attention to them.
They do a touch here,
touch there.
They'd tell you to eat something and you're like,
wait a second,
I don't have that fucking pain no more.
What'd you do?
You know,
like what the fuck did you do?
boulder was,
is the home of that stuff,
right?
It's the home of that stuff.
It's where it breeds out to the rest of the country.
You believe in that stuff.
He believed people have like the Voodoo touch and they can rub your back and all
of a sudden it feels better.
I'm not sure.
I mean he gives,
got the Indian,
the Indian of touch a couple of ways,
you know?
Right.
There's this other guy that says your frame is all that much,
but you know what man,
a year ago when I would see movement training,
I thought it was crazy.
And now I think it makes a lot of sense.
And now that I see a lot of high level Jujitsu schools incorporating that as a
class and their workouts,
so it's gotta be doing something for you.
That stuff that,
uh,
the guy didn't,
the beginning Hixon the documentary,
all that stuff.
People,
and it looks very simple.
It's very,
it's very similar to,
very similar,
you know,
bro,
we've evolved.
We've evolved in every fucking level from technology and the main training,
you know,
10 years ago they put a chicken on the floor and you chased it for speed,
whatever the fuck you did in those days.
I don't know.
Now it's completely different.
But that was what was so interesting about Hickson Hickson and figured this out
in 1994.
I mean,
that guy was a Yogi.
He was a legitimate Yogi.
You mean Hixon does some spectacular
shit.
He does.
He'll stand on a balance bar and do a full split standing up,
grabs his foot and puts it over his head like a fucking ballerina.
Plus he'll choke you out.
I mean,
his,
his ability to control his body is really freaky.
Like he was an incredible,
um,
bodyweight athlete.
Like the stuff that he could do with his body just in terms of like gymnastic
movements and stuff like that and yoga movements and stretching movements.
Like very,
very unusually dexterous.
Dexterous.
Is that the word?
Yeah,
good dexterity,
amazing dexterity.
But,
uh,
just his Jujitsu was so high level on top of that.
So he had this deep knowledge of Jujitsu of all the positions,
a kids,
his basics,
we're so fucking good.
Everything they to this day,
him and his son crone,
they,
they use the same standard Jujitsu that everyone has always used.
There's not like a lot of fancy crazy weird shit you've never seen before.
Triangles armbars chokes and they're just razor sharp out them and that's like a
Gracie family thing.
You think about like [inaudible] same shit like Darce choke I guess like the
most unconventional thing that he does a lot of time he does like a standard
Gracie attack armbars triangles,
[inaudible] chokes.
It's like they have that style of attack and especially Hickson and his son
crone is just at this Ninja level,
this monk level where it's just,
they do the standard Jujitsu.
There's no crazy weird tricks coming your way.
No Burn Bolo both by the God,
I mean they know it.
I'm sure.
I'm sure he could do it.
I mean I'm sure all every high level guys aware of pretty much every technique
at this point.
Like if they're competitive or if they train into competitive gym or the curious
or they work with athletes.
Look at the Derek Brunson.
He's fighting out of Houston,
Texas.
You know what he's thinking about right now,
right.
Was like,
I'm knocking on this motherfucking house,
so I go back and get myself some barbecue in this mother fucking shit.
Maybe he's thinking about Roy Nelson as if it was a white cop.
It's a fucking nightmare.
What's going on on Jamie?
Can you put the card up and one of the TV so we can see what's coming up next.
Nice.
Needed a body.
That's a really,
it's this and those aren't,
yes.
The dos Anjos fight to five rounder,
right?
Yeah.
Roy Nelson,
I knew him back in the day when he was just a Jujitsu guy before he ever did any
MMA.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure he was in Brazil with us when a Eddie had that match with a
boiler and I flew down with them.
That was 2003.
Roy Nelson was a real hot,
I mean,
it still is like a real high level grappler.
He um,
beat Frank Mir and a grappling competition,
a straight graveling competitions,
like some ridiculous amount,
like a just outpointed that shit out of him.
But uh,
those like the Frank Mir lazy days,
Frank Mir has gone through,
you know,
days where he's less dedicated days where he's more dedicated.
Well,
he's asking to be released now.
he got something happened.
You got,
there's some drug test issues.
What was the Frank Mir drug test issue?
Is it a steroid thing?
Kangaroo meat.
That's right.
Right.
They said that they tested that they put the steroids that kangaroo meat or some
shit.
So when might you serious?
No.
Yeah,
that's what he said.
He ate kangaroo.
Oh,
what'd he went to Australia?
He tested positive after Australia.
Come on.
He really blamed it on kangaroo.
Damn.
He's Roy Nelson knees to the thigh are impressive.
I like what he's doing there.
He really did say that.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That's what he ate.
Was it?
They may be they blah,
blah,
blah.
I swear to God mere question.
In April if his positive tests could be the result of tainted kangaroo meat.
He consumed it.
Australia.
I have a feeling he did that with a half a smile on his face.
Oh Shit.
Good.
Very broad.
I told Ya directs like wait a second,
I gotta get this out of Las Vegas.
Oh Shit.
It's Derrick Lewis.
Would I call them dark brown?
Sorry about that.
MMM.
See now this is a bad spot for him cause Roy has a fucking nasty ground game.
Everybody thinks a Roy's being,
this dude would just beat you up if you stand and trade with them.
But Roy can control motherfuckers on the ground,
man.
Yeah,
he,
no,
he lost to a Andre Arlovski in elite x z.
But that's what I detail or what I taught when I call one of the most crooked
organizations that ever showed MMA crooked in not maybe that they cheated but
crooked in like the way they interpreted the rules of MMA.
They would stand,
be blunt,
they were down for like 15 seconds.
Like if you went to the ground,
you've got to submit somebody quick.
They were just standing people up.
Oh Damn.
This is Christ.
Oh Jesus.
Roy just got blasted in the gut and another one to the gut and to the face.
Oh Shit.
Oh is in trouble.
Oh,
need of the body.
we've got that Gable grip though.
Can you get them down?
You got the escrip rather.
Damn.
This is a fight for his life here,
Derek.
Punch man.
That's where his experience comes in though.
He got them waffle and gave him a little chance to breathe and fucking thank
clear.
His hair,
his head.
He's still in trouble,
dude.
Cool.
Louis can crack,
man.
He really hits hard.
That was an excellent exchange too.
Ooh,
crazy sport.
What were we talking about right before this?
We were talking about something super important.
CBC Oil show like that started to bring up to what's going on in America.
Oh,
the sheer active situation going on too right now in Dallas.
What's going on?
There's supposedly a shooter shooting cops right now and during a protest,
no shit.
No Shit.
This is what's going to happen.
No Shit I can't take today.
Take call me,
goes this date.
I go,
listen,
six black guys are going to get together and start ambushing motherfuckers and
that's it.
This is going to go cause you can't keep doing this.
Oh yeah,
this is,
this was fun.
Oh Roy,
he's taking some bombs,
man.
Roizen trouble.
Jesus.
Derek is in excellent shape too,
man,
cause he's hitting him when some hard fucking shots and he keeps coming forward
and Roy can take a punch like no other and it gets the takedown.
Goddamn full mount.
Not Good.
No Bueno for Derek.
This could be a wrap man.
I'm telling you.
Oh the end of the round dude,
Roy Nelson mounted on you is one of the worst situations ever.
That gut and all that body weight is all centered.
It's like having like a giant 400 pound kettle bell sitting on your Dick.
Like the way he mounts you.
You don't want to release.
I control people.
I feel bad,
especially when I'm sweating and shit.
They smelled my stomach juice and pizzas and pretzels.
Fuck you stomach.
I get my like I tried to get my rib eyes.
It's too bad.
No,
no.
Look at these fucking shots.
Derek's Landon.
Jesus.
Roy's tough because Derek was beaten the shit out of him.
This is good.
As Derek's several overlord,
like those combinations,
he looks more more settled and he's fucking calm looking at,
I'm Tom.
We gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Imagine if he grabs the mic and says,
forget it man.
God Damn it.
Look at him.
He's not even breathing.
Well,
you know what?
Derek has also had quite a few fights in the UFC now and he's gotten more and
more at home there and more and more comfortable with the experience.
We get that Nice smoothies right out of the way of that right hand.
This is good.
As he's ever looked mad,
I think it looks great.
Doesn't mean that he can't still get caught because Roy hits fucking hard and
Roy knows how to win.
Oh Shit.
No.
Yeah,
it's really weird.
Roy's been lingering for years,
bro.
He's like,
God,
you don't go away.
Roy is a tank.
He really is a tank and he's a guy who probably should be fighting at one 85 how
about that?
Okay.
Yeah,
no,
I mean if he had the kind of discipline that some of these dudes have like dos
Anjos that cut way down.
But who knows?
Man,
maybe part of why he's so good is because he's a small man fighting as a
heavyweight and can take unbelievable punches and kicks and hits really hard.
But he's not like a physically big guy.
Yeah.
I mean I guess he is in his weight because he's about to 65 but if you got rid
of all the body fat on him,
how much do you think you'd weigh?
Two 30 to 20
like quite honestly,
if you put him in the same kind of condition that say like a Robbie Lawler's in,
get him down to his optimal fighting weight.
What is your way to 10?
Yeah,
look,
he's got lats.
Oh,
he's a tech.
He's got lots.
He's got traps.
So it was just a stomach.
Yeah.
Well all that stuff under the legs,
it's long as shit.
Look at the legs now.
I remember when he loses those,
that wait,
those legs are going to be fucking savages because they'd been holding up a
house.
Yeah,
that's true.
The last fucking 10 years,
so yeah,
he's got,
he's halfway there.
If he just went on a diet,
he's never going to do that though.
That's part of,
is a part of his flair.
That's just who he is.
I mean,
it's amazing.
He's a world class fighter and he's built like a guy who works at a gas station.
No dirt,
no disrespect.
Roy knows I'm a big fan.
He's a great guy.
It's tough as fuck too.
Just tough as fuck.
He's one of them.
All them brothers,
motherfuckers,
you know,
he's one of them.
Allman brothers.
Fighters don't fucking come all night.
Hope will show up with a bottle of Jack.
You bust that limp.
They just,
but Jacqueline,
I keep fighting the fuck stitches.
He's had some spectacular knockouts in UFC too.
I think of the guys.
He's Code Mitre,
own check Congo.
They can't check Congo,
right?
Yeah.
Did he say he did?
I know Frank Mir caught Congo and then put them away with a choke.
Am I confusing it to Oh oh shit.
So I control not good for Derek and he's only shot him fucking those beers.
He did beat him.
He knocked him out.
Yeah.
Um,
this is terrible because this is two minutes to go in the round and uh,
Derek is not moving that much,
which means Derek is probably starting to fade.
He blew his gas tank trying to put Roy away.
I think we're seeing the same strategy play out that we saw with Joe band and
with Derek Lewis went for it.
Sprinted empty that tank and a worse situation for sure though,
for Louis men to be on the bottom.
Roy gets that fucking that um,
mounted crucifix all the time.
That's what he's looking for.
He's gonna Punch Derek in the face until Derek gives him that right arm.
He's going to take that right here.
I'm shoving in between his two legs and once he gets that arm in between his two
legs,
once he feels like can open it,
he's like trying to bait Derek.
Oh,
okay.
Now he's got his back.
Wow.
Dark yet that we can't fuck.
I ain't fucking around.
Back up to his feet.
That's strong.
That's a strong move.
That's impressive because Roy Bam takes from my back down Roy's ground games
type,
but Roy,
he doesn't like to take that back.
That's weird.
But it was tough to take it back.
When you a Chubby dude.
That's what it is right over there.
Yeah.
It's time because of his gut.
If you've got them from a turtle,
it works and you lay on them and you pull them back.
But it's tough.
I guess it's sort of a fulcrum point,
right?
Oh Shit.
He took a hard elbow to the head by Derek and attempting that takedown and now
he's back.
Interesting.
Okay.
Back to [inaudible].
That's his shit.
That's his shit for MMA.
He likes this.
This is how he stopped Kimbo slice on the ultimate fighter.
He's gonna pin that fucking right arm in between his two legs.
It just doesn't want to lose the position again because he doesn't have much
time here,
so he's probably just going to try to beat him up from here.
He's smothering him with his gut,
get that pizza on the fucking head and garlic.
Chili heard him left,
took
whoa.
Jesus Christ.
So he's tired.
He starts off to have that guy look up and he's like,
God damn,
that white dude stinks.
Well,
this topic up,
my God,
Deb face,
that's when he forced him to move.
He forced him to move when he was gut smothering them.
Roy Nelson with the powerful leg kick.
I'm just a big fan of Roy Nelson who voiced stands for,
you know,
that's as American as it gets zone.
I love him.
I love the big crazy beard.
He's fun.
It looked like my titties,
right?
That though all fucked up for the side.
They sweat.
You get that to the sweat on you with that Pretzel stubbing sweat.
That shit deadly.
The Pretzel Stomachs.
I smell my rash guard when I know.
I definitely don't.
Definitely don't.
It's time for a [inaudible].
What's going to have here happen here?
Give me a Joey karate prediction.
Third round joined karate predictions.
Roy Nelson is getting a little bit of confidence.
He might take them down and do exactly what you said.
The fucking Tomahawk with the legs,
that amount in the crucifix,
if he can get them down.
Derek is taking some big deep breaths and um,
you know,
this is a high pace fight,
real high paced fight.
And when two guys start getting tired,
the guy with the greater wrestling is able to usually impose his wrestling game
better than the guy with the pretty decent takedown defense,
which is where I would put Derrick Lewis.
So like they start making mistakes and they get really tired and a guy with a
lot of experience in grappling,
like Roy does a great job of uh,
forcing guys in a bad positions when it takes him down.
So if he could,
if he could push the pace now he's got a much better chance of getting Louis
down than he did in the first or second round because Louis has to bargain.
Like,
how much energy do I use to fight off this take down?
He's punched him in the knee and Derek complaint,
that's interesting.
Look at this.
He's punching the inside of his leg.
You know,
sometimes a guy will like let the fight go to the ground because like he just
can't defend it anymore.
And then he wants to take a little break and then try to scramble.
But you can't afford to do that in the third round,
especially if it gets any deeper here.
You were like four minutes in now or four minutes ago.
So you know Derek's trying to pummel under,
he's going to fall into that KIA team.
Roy just Roy just has no fear of his guillotine
and boom,
he's down.
There it is.
And Roy is going to step over.
Okay.
So now he's got three minutes and 30 seconds to work.
And if one of the first thing Roy's going to do,
Roy doesn't fuck around,
Roy is going to establish a position and then he's gonna move to half guard or
move to a side control.
He's gonna establish like some way to control his body like head and arm
control.
And then he does like your standard Shinon insteps slice pins down.
He's a Henzel Gracie black belt.
Izzy.
Yup.
In New York that,
I mean he trained with a lot of different people,
but I'm pretty sure he got his black belt from Hanzo.
Roy,
super legit on the ground watch.
She's going to slice down,
just just posturing up on him here.
It doesn't feel like Derek is a moving his hips at all.
Derek is like an exploder.
He's like a wait for his moment and explode sort of a guy.
But he's eating some shots here with Roy on top of them before I can just keep,
keep pinned down here.
Like this was headed that awkward angle as an awkward place to be.
Man.
He doesn't want any more.
So he's going to see,
it's like Derek,
like bides is time waits for his energy levels to restore and then just hoaxes
way standing.
I mean for sure he's got technique.
The way he got up that was all smooth and everything like that.
But what I'm saying is like he's strong as fuck,
but this fucking guy resting on.
Yeah,
it takes it.
So,
yeah,
no it does.
No.
And Roy,
I believe me,
it's making that guy carry all of his weight.
Look,
I like how much he's driving into them with his shoulders pinned against them.
It makes it harder for him to breathe.
He's got real good head control like Roy's.
Oh,
he's gotta be careful with those.
Oh No.
Yeah,
he likes sacrifices.
A couple of those elbows to get them down.
This is not good for Derek.
He's definitely losing this round.
Backups his feet again,
man.
So impressive.
That's impressive.
Cause uh,
Roy is good at holding dude's down,
man.
It just shows you how tough Lewis is and how strong he is,
but he just doesn't have a,
it doesn't seem like he
has the horsepower or the gas tank to sustain and they can't get away from him.
He manages to get back up to his feet,
but then he can't get away from it.
We go here.
We got big John McCarthy stows into fans.
I was doing this shit.
You see on the weekends the baby.
Oh,
let's do this shit.
Well,
I just took to pay gas.
Deep breath.
Okay.
Wow.
These people,
he's gonna kick 'em
okay.
He's telegraphing that left kick.
Yeah.
Derek was given that one away.
The best guys.
Let's go co shit out of that.
Oh Shit.
Get out of there.
Oh Jesus.
Fucking Christ.
Jesus is a body.
Ooh.
The clinch again.
And Derek just went hall,
man.
God dammit.
This mother fuckers on top of me.
Boy,
teddy juice getting this teddy juice on me.
[inaudible] juice off,
man.
Come on man.
This is fucking hot dogs.
This one little flying it out.
20 seconds to go.
Does he get free?
Yes he does.
Oh Shit.
Left hand.
God Damn Derrick Lewis.
Woo.
But he don't give a fuck this walking.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh to just one hour.
He's hurt.
Oh my goodness.
Look at him.
Look at me.
Oh my goodness.
That's white brilliance,
right?
You just lose a tooth.
He lost something.
Mouth piece,
something teeth.
He don't give a fuck Jack.
Dude.
He got correct.
He got cracked.
Watch.
Here it is.
Here's a right hand.
Boom.
Oh,
that was slobber.
That's a slobber.
Knocker.
Hmm.
That's officially a slobber.
Knocker.
Damn.
Roy Nelson has a chin of the gods.
Look at his Chin that is in his Chin is insane.
His ability to absorb punishment is just superhuman.
He's just,
just give him the fight just for taking that punch and stay there.
That just goes to show you a hard mark hotheads mark hut and knocked him out.
He,
he killed him with an upper cut and walked away.
That just shows you what a bad mother fucker.
Mark Hunt is.
Roy Nelson man takes a shot as good as any human being that's ever lived.
And for as long as he's been doing it,
I mean,
he's been taken shots for a long fucking time.
It still has an iron jaw.
I mean that was a perfect punch from a knockout artists that landed right on the
tip of his chin,
snapped his head back.
Okay.
And the dude survived.
It's a tank.
Yeah.
Who won that fight?
Roy takedowns,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
But if you look at it like who was closer to finishing the fight?
It was the one round with Derek and then the third round with Derek.
Those exchanges were way more dangerous for Roy then anything that Roy did to
him on the ground.
Cause Roy never really established,
um,
any good position for a long period time.
Got The mound,
but it was at the end of the round.
He got site control and he like was trying to get the amount of crucifix and
Derek kept getting up so it wasn't a whole lot done on the ground other than
some,
you know,
decent ground impound.
Ooh,
Split Decision Ladies and gentlemen.
First judge scores are for Louis.
No Sir.
Second for Nelson.
Derrick Lewis.
See,
judges are starting to look at take downs as being less important than damage
done.
And if you want to go by damage done,
you got the first round.
Lot of damage done,
a lot of damage done by Louis.
You had the second round,
lot of take downs,
right?
How many times did Roy take them down?
Three.
And then the third round take downs.
But Derrick hit him with some hard shots and had him in trouble
either way,
man.
What a fight.
See,
this is one of the reasons why hate,
um,
like those,
uh,
the win and loss money.
Boom.
Look at this hair comes crank.
Who takes that shot?
Who fucking takes that shot?
What was human being?
Takes that shot.
That is insane.
Roy Nelson's jaw is fucking insane.
You would,
you'd have to fly in specialists.
If he punched me like that.
Royal blue is going to go out dancing tonight.
You probably pick up from chewing tobacco on the way home.
Oh,
unbelievable.
But anyway,
what I was going to say is sometimes they get bummed out that um,
that like someone makes less money than that in a split decision.
Especially I feel like a split decision so many times.
I don't agree so many times.
And the difference between like three people,
three people's opinions.
So it's really only two people's opinions against it
and that's going to cost you half of your money.
That seems so crazy.
That seems like that's something that shouldn't,
I feel like maybe they should be like different kinds of women bonuses or the
very least they should share something.
If it's like a split decision,
you know,
I know the UFC privately bonuses a lot of people,
but that's not even what I'm talking about.
I'm just talking about like this,
the idea of a way,
I mean,
everybody's trying to win.
You know how much when they go to the show up,
they know they're getting a certain amount,
right?
Like,
uh,
it's a private company,
first of all,
obviously I work for them and I can't
divulge things that I know that,
that I'm not supposed to talk about.
But it's a private company and they prefer to pay people non publicly with a lot
of this stuff.
They do.
I can't say much more than that because it's not my place,
you know?
Um,
I'm obviously not a money person.
I don't pay attention to how the business side of shit of this especially works.
There's lots of different sports so that players will get fucked out of a
contract.
Like I've,
I've known baseball players have a,
maybe we're,
their team wasn't going to make the playoffs,
but that is really good.
And he has that performance bonuses built into his contract and at the end of
the year they'll,
maybe one,
he needs to pitch one more inning or even one more out and they'll take them out
of the game.
So I don't have to pay him like $1 million or some shit like that when the
players also feel like that guy deserves it because he worked all year for it,
did everything he was supposed to do.
Right.
And the owner just says,
ah,
not going to pay that money today.
Sorry.
Yeah,
that's fucked.
But I guess that's like we were talking about um,
performance bonus money where um,
baseball teams,
Jamie was saying,
we'll take a guy out if he needs to pitch like one more inning and he gets like
a million dollar bonus.
They just bench him.
They just won't let him play so that they don't have to pay him that bonus,
which totally makes sense.
I mean,
especially if they're winning,
they're ahead.
They don't need them.
I mean,
it all depends on like how and in losing situations too though.
There's planning the thing out for fans to watch a game and they're just,
people have sometimes they even know the situation,
like this guy's going to make 500 g's if he gets three hits today and they're
like,
I got to and he's not going to play for the next four innings.
It it's crazy.
Jamie clubs,
one night 11 I was at the fucking comedy store and Paul Mooney was onstage
talking about Barry Bonds.
He was talking about how Barry Bonds that weren't going to let that white boy
break the record.
I behave was going up against the steroid guy.
I'll never forget.
He kept saying that Shit onstage and then we're going to let that,
that pool a little black boy break that record all this stuff.
The next day I woke up to the plains,
Haiti and I'll never forget,
saved myself.
Jesus Christ.
He was right dead.
Never going to let that Barry bonds with the fucking battery died.
That's how much they want out of fucking way.
I'm not the Jamie cranked this up so I can hear what they're saying about Mark
Hunt.
I'm so happy that Mark Hunt is the guy fighting Brock Lesnar.
Okay.
To ever compete in the heavyweight division,
the
heavyweight contender,
a guy was meet with some of the best fighters in the world and a guy who has
absolutely one punch knock out.
She just fucking smokes people,
man.
Be Mark Hunt just smokes people.
Does he book?
I'm going to try to take him down.
It's fighting evil.
I don't have to sit here and build this way.
Holy Shit.
I'm excited about this.
Okay.
I was more excited about Cormier and Jon Jones.
I wasn't that.
We're excited about this fucking fight,
this fight.
Mark Hunt and Broccoli in there.
Fuck.
Ooh.
I can't hope mark club picks him up and throws his head on the fucking room.
Ah.
That's what I give a fuck.
What is pissed off to be fucking pissed off.
He's pissed off right now,
so yeah,
he should not see what the fuck this goes.
This is going to be a good fight.
Um,
yeah man.
I'm interested.
They got me.
I'm interested and it,
the very few guys could be coming from pro wrestling,
you know,
and having a used to have fought in MMA and come back and get you excited like
this guy.
I mean,
he's a legit freak of the freaks.
look at the size of that motherfucker,
dude,
look at that.
Boom.
Thank you.
Wait,
no,
that was a fight where,
yeah.
Oh Shane car.
When I look at it,
look how he would,
he,
he beats the fuck out of Frank Mir here.
I mean,
just smashed him.
He's a big boy.
That is the biggest you're ever going to see as far as like legit super athletes
in MMA that fight at 265 pounds.
Cause that's,
you know,
they have to maybe some people don't know that for the heavyweight division you,
it's not unlimited.
Wait,
heavyweight division has a weight limit and that limit is 265 pounds.
Everything above 265 pounds is super heavyweight.
And we don't have a super heavyweight division in the UFC.
So if you're like a super giant guy like the mountain,
that game of Thrones demon.
Dude,
that guy could not find the OCD,
can't make the wait that guy's way over 300 pounds.
Right?
He's enormous.
So if they ever wanted to do that super freak division,
like they would have to open it up and then they would have to start having
fights in there.
But I just don't know if there's enough 265 pound plus elite MMA athletes do it
all.
Be a bunch of fucking ex linemen,
man.
That's what it would be.
A bunch of ex Lyman that walk around it too.
You know.
[inaudible] five.
Let me ask you this.
The x linemen who are,
uh,
you know a lot about football,
so if a guy's like a fucking worldclass Lineman,
some beast of a man,
um,
what would that guy have to,
how much would he have to lose to compete as an MMA fighter?
20 pounds.
Maybe that's it.
If the alignment that's walking around at two 95,
he's got a tremendous foot work.
If he's an offensive line,
defensive line,
right?
So half my work is done.
He's got strong fucking feet.
Yeah.
We got to work on the striking his takedowns it
once you break the take down to them.
Jill football channel side of that beautiful tape.
[inaudible] beautiful football style tape.
Now you went four feet.
Well,
Chelsea Clinton was an elite athlete,
channel son,
a very,
very high level wrestler.
If you could teach somebody who's six foot six two five to check a motherfucker
down.
Wait,
shale don't die.
You get done.
What's going on over here?
The eighth starved death gets stuck.
Who is this?
Bjorn.
Oh,
this is the rock.
The mountain guy.
Beyond Sin Bra br.
How do you say that?
Johnson.
Doris.
Bj O,
r n s.
S.
O N.
Bjornsen six foot nine and weighs 403 pounds.
Jeez.
Co riced.
After injuring his knee and basketball,
we started competing in strong man competition.
When Iceland strongest man competition that came out sixth and the 2011 world's
strongest man competition contest.
Haute Shit Dude.
Wow.
As a giant giant dude.
Fucking amen.
He he bench presses 500 pounds and he weighs 400 pounds somehow.
I think he's a pussy.
So you can do bitch,
I want you bench bro.
It fell on him and talking.
I vent 600 pounds.
It was like talking shit to the guys in the room with them.
Like you ain't been,
you ain't big like me.
Okay.
Uh,
um,
Mark Bell,
you know dude who's been on our podcast for and his brother Chris from a bigger,
stronger,
faster.
He just had some shit on his Instagram the other day where he's benching way
over 500 pounds.
She's fucking go real estate wrong.
Like that guy has huge fucking huge and that's all he wants to do is just lift
heavy shit.
He's got an awesome gym.
Created this product is,
that's what he's real lifting.
Watch this shit.
We'll cut a problem.
He's got this uh,
thing called the slingshot and it,
uh,
it supports your elbows and your shoulders when you're a,
when you're benching.
It's actually a pretty interesting invention.
I look at the size of this motherfucker.
Look at how much weight he's pushing out.
That is insanity.
That's a quarter of a ton.
What in the fuck him.
That was his friend.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
there's ones,
oh,
that's big,
Steve.
Sorry on fucking believable.
Yeah,
I should know that's on him.
I can't tell you all.
See actually see his face until he gets up and then he's all of a sudden Mark's
a ginger.
But this video is a him,
but I know,
I know one is Instagram of him lifting ungodly.
Wait,
still all those big muscles.
You've discussed it before.
You know what?
Jujitsu and stuff,
the endurance factors go up.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's super heavyweight division.
They're going to be huffing and puffing on the third fucking round.
Especially if they come in.
They're yoked to the gills.
Yeah.
I wonder,
you know,
I mean there's very few heavyweights other than Cain Velasquez that can fight
like a lighter weight fighter,
you know,
and cane in his prime in particular had just this unbelievable endurance
threshold.
He could just put paces on guys they just could not tolerate.
And you would watch it.
I'd watch it like ringside and I would try to think,
have I ever seen it?
Ha,
I hit a heavyweight
that active that can keep it up for five rounds.
There's no,
no,
the answer's no.
I've never seen anybody as fit as Cain was in his prime.
Like no one has the uh,
the kind of endurance that guy be.
He'll be there again this weekend.
It will be that same condition.
He's 100% healthy.
I hope so.
He had back surgery,
man.
You never know what the fuck's going to happen to an athlete after back surgery.
Back surgery is a very tricky,
they're pulling pieces of his disks out,
you know,
cause it's disk was impeding on his nerves impinging I guess.
Um,
and then he's also had shoulder surgery.
He's had knee surgery.
There's a lot going on.
I'm like,
no one's a bigger Cain Velasquez fan than me.
I,
I personally think there's only two guys ever that you could put in contention
for being the greatest of all time.
And that's Kane.
And are those the only two?
Well it's as far as heavyweights,
those are the two.
The only,
well I guess you got to argue for doom.
Well Sorta,
but Allister,
certainly a combat sports athlete.
I mean he's one of the most decorated ever.
And you won the k one Grand Prix.
Anyone strike Strikeforce and dream.
So he was the heavyweight champion of three different organizations.
Just never could win.
I never has one or even had a shot until this next upcoming fight.
Anderson Silva fight Daniel Cormier at UFC 200
is that true?
That's true.
TMZ sports has confirmed he was bullshit and this afternoon I,
this is so good.
He put a flyer out with UFC 200 that is crazy.
If he does that because let me tell you something.
Daniel Cormier is a very strong man and he's a powerful wrestler and Daniel
Cormier was throwing dudes around at heavyweight and sometimes people forget
what he did to rumble Johnson.
I rumble Johnson Rumble Johnson hits as hard as any fucking light heavyweight
he's ever walked the face of the planet.
He cracked me on the button,
me goes down,
gets back up,
whether it's a storm and start to ragdoll in them.
It starts breaking them.
It takes them down,
strangles him,
broke them and strangle them and and rumbles way bigger than Anderson.
You know,
and this is 40 year old Anderson.
It's is a a very interesting,
um,
very interesting fight.
That hint that I understood would want that because if it was like the Anderson
that Jay had just knocked out,
Forrest Griffin,
I'd be like,
Oh shit.
Yeah,
let's see that.
You know,
cause Anderson's two fights at light heavyweight or three Stephan Bonner was at
light heavyweight too,
right?
Wasn't it?
I want to say it is.
I want to say that was a non title affair because I think it was,
um,
that was a headliner in Brazil.
Find out what weight Anderson was when he fought.
Stephan Bonner.
Two Oh five was it two or five?
I think so.
Well,
bond or fought Jon Jones.
Bonner Bonner has always been a two oh five it'd be,
we thought Jon Jones,
205-FIVE-FOUR-3205.
It had to be two oh five two.
Oh,
but I'm,
I'm just talking about mass bonding has never made one
85 so what am I even saying?
What's the outlook box?
But I'm interested in that.
Just a new product that you guys are,
no,
this is just a,
just thought weed.
Okay.
No,
no,
I want a Panorai then no quickie.
How are you feeling after those three things?
You don't mean this is,
this is like an appetizer for uncle Joey.
This is like going to fuck at Ruth Chris.
We did get the clamps.
I don't know how you do it.
I built it.
I work in,
I've been training,
I've been taking this breast spray recently.
How good is it?
How many millet gets me so paranoid?
Does it?
There's something about the breast spray that just hits you with this burst of
paranoia and um,
it's not the breath spray,
it's edibles.
It's just really hope edibles.
He started feeling,
there's a point on the plane where I get rid of,
but that's the point of the plane with my legs can't stop moving and that's the
fucking worst that happens over a certain altitude.
With edibles,
my legs can't stop or anything like that.
The crazy leg syndrome.
So it without the bulls,
you can't fucking judge nothing.
These,
at least I know I take four or five weeks.
I see the devil because I fall asleep.
That's it.
I fall asleep.
I get up at four fucking cotton mouth thirsty.
Don't you feel like those?
Feel the doubt.
Meet the devil moments are actually a good for you because even though you,
you,
you get all fucking crazy paranoid and weirded out and you feel vulnerable and
strange when it's over you,
you appreciate life more.
It's almost like camping out in the forest for a few days and not having air
conditioning and coming home and just having a nice cool glass of ice tea.
That sizzle first show for Dolphy sizzled.
As I was getting on stage,
the attaboy hit me punch to the stomach.
I thought I had to sit down and I walked out on stage.
It was surreal and it kicked into the next level when I walked out once the
adrenaline and met the THC that's just ran with it and it walked out and it
ended up perfect.
But Jesus Christ,
you never know what you're putting in your body with those fucking things you
never know.
Never fucking know.
Well,
especially from new sources,
the ship that brought your Jane,
what's your old school Jamie?
Cause that's how I roll.
What do you got
Joe g is,
when are you going to commit to a fanny pack?
What does this,
this is it.
This is the visit that that Sarah,
this is it brought to sorrow.
My Man Chris sent me.
Oh Nice.
I got everything.
Get I got this refund.
Joey Diaz has a fanny pack.
Ladies and gentlemen,
when are you going to get a family?
I got the fucking lighter.
They only got the fucking look.
I even got quite loose.
I got,
I got one coin.
Lou left Cosby,
quaint little gorilla biscuits and shit.
That is a big fanny pack.
Yeah.
This is the real deal.
Hopefully the big one.
He he,
he's had more than one size,
right?
No,
this is it.
I think it's just the one he sells as the Joe Rogan utility pack or something
like that
and this just happened.
Made to write anything.
It makes us happy.
He makes it easy.
Makes it really good.
Gies man,
this is the shit to fly with.
Oh yeah.
This is how I fly it.
This,
that's it.
Yeah.
It's easy and off you put it,
you talk to you.
You still keep your wallet in your front pocket because yeah,
those fucking,
you know those people.
Fuck people,
those people.
But uh,
no.
This is tremendous.
You got your keys.
You get him.
Chris due to man's got a real estate company week.
He's coming next week,
but we're going to be an oh,
he's,
yeah,
he's Friday night.
He's at the Ice House.
Okay.
He's coming in for Ebi.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
You like the Ice House next Friday night?
No,
I'm not there for that.
No.
So here it goes.
A dos Anjos is about to get on stage,
step into the octagon looking shredded.
What do you think about this fight,
Joey Diaz?
I know you've been wanting this fight for a long time.
I think you're an Alvarez Fan,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I think this is a real barn burner of a fight.
I think so too.
I think this is hard against fucking tremendous skill.
I mean,
this guy's got like,
he's a great decorator that you get two guys got like 19 stripes on his black
belt.
This is the real deal.
This fucking guy.
Yeah.
Those sign just has a very good Jujitsu game.
But he's also,
his striking is,
I mean what he did to cowboy Cerrone showed that his striking his fucking spooky
and shit too and what he did to pedis is even scarier.
What he is more than anything,
man is super serious and super focused.
His,
that is a focused man.
And uh,
so who's number one in this division of him?
Want to be sad?
No,
no,
no.
He's,
he's the champion.
I beat number.
Good.
Madoff is definitely the number one contender and the biggest threat to him
because number Grumet off beat him and he beat him pretty handily just a couple
of years ago.
And then number give,
Madoff had series of injuries,
had surgery on his knee,
hurt it again,
had a lot of shit happened.
[inaudible] years.
Yup.
Still Aka he,
Habib,
Norma Madoff is a fucking nightmare.
Nightmare inside the octagon.
His grappling is so high level,
man.
You see any so ferocious in his approaches?
It's not,
I mean it's just,
it's a sea of salt.
You fast and hard and when he gets a hold of you in a clinch man,
he's doing a lot of crazy shit.
He's tripping you.
He's,
he's,
he'll throw guys he takes guys down with doubles his,
his grip is insane.
Like he clamps a hold of guys and you see when he's clamping a hold of them,
let like Whoa,
like he's just got this level of squeeze and this level of like physical
strength and the understanding of how to manipulate bodies.
That's just at a super high level.
When he ragdoll dos Anjos,
that's when it really opened my eyes.
I was like,
wow,
I did not expect that.
Like I expected a good fight.
I expected a struggle.
But he did the same thing to Nate Diaz.
He beat the fuck out of Nate Diaz man.
And when you watch the way he did it,
you're like,
wow,
this guy's a tank.
And that,
you know,
again,
nick curse on trained athlete and a curse on is of the belief that the strength
and conditioning is everything.
Man.
You're gonna know how to put a little bitch down cause the old member it.
You do not.
I though,
I mean the last I heard he have him working with fighters is Bj.
He might've worked with other fighters and I don't know about,
but he's a guy that I would love to sit down and talk to because he was a genius
man.
Super Genius.
So it was Todd Marinovich.
Now what as an artist now stop playing football.
Our 30 for 30 on him I think.
And at the end was the biggest that they talk about how the guy from the Raiders
got them arrested.
Hmm.
I don't remember the whole thing.
You put the coconut socks so he will get low a draft pick and he could steal a
minute.
Shit.
Really?
Yeah.
Davis is the real fucking deal.
I'm surprised Al Davis saying,
Hey,
Trump's running mate.
That's what the fuck that we'll link to that a few years ago.
Yeah,
that's right.
He did die.
What the fuck am I thinking?
The fucking drafted you would do kinky Shit,
you know.
So here's the question.
Should Bruce Buffer break out the buffer?
Three 60 for UFC 200 when he introduces Brock Lesnar.
Especially now that Brock Lesnar is in the main event,
he's doing something completely different.
What's he going to do?
Like though?
He went to three no sunshine,
you know made dog.
I know.
Thinks what he's doing.
What's he doing?
It's a surprise.
And you serious?
Yeah,
he's doing like a pink type deal.
Oh yeah.
They would come out like going get off the flag on up and we like that.
Like that.
He's on the off of the top dressed up like an angel swing down silks.
Yeah.
Look at Eddie Alvarez.
Got Two black eyes.
That's how hard he's been training.
He's coming into this fight.
Beat up.
Eddie Alvarez has two black eyes,
man.
I mean he wasn't lying about a sparring.
150 rounds.
Yeah.
Very interesting man.
Cause Alvarez is the type of dude who rises to the occasion.
He's got greatness in him,
man.
I mean he's had some wins and some losses.
Nice inside leg kick.
But at the end of the day,
this dude's a savage and the most exciting,
biggest challenge is where he's going to fight as best.
And that's what we're looking at goes on at Alvarez in the most dangerous
situation he's been in,
in years.
And the most important.
That's where a guy like Eddie Alvarez will fucking come to life.
And that's what makes this exciting.
Dosantos has to be aware.
I'm,
and Alvarez is no fucking joke.
He's got a mind,
his p's and q's as he makes his,
when the differences dos Anjos throws a lot of kicks man.
And uh,
I'll read through a couple of Nice inside leg kicks,
but that's generally not what he does.
Once,
once he starts brawling,
he'll widened his stance and throw bombs.
Whereas dos Anjos we'll stick with the kickboxing game.
He'll stick kicking those legs and mixing things up.
It's just a matter of who strategy works the best.
But I,
I liked that Alvarez came out with those kicks,
but he hasn't thrown very many sense.
No,
Joe Rogan.
What a weird gift that
it,
it'd be a professional fighter.
I want 50 fucking five what a wig gift.
Yeah.
What a weird,
you know,
dangerous choice in life,
man.
Crazy.
Just unbelievably difficult journey you're on.
Especially at this level.
I mean,
look how good these guys are.
Dos Anjos just caught him at the end with that left hand and fatigue may very
well play a factor in this fight because one of the things again about dos Anjos
not to harp on this,
but his conditioning is exceptional.
What he did with with pedes in particular,
oh,
guillotine getting Eddie's in trouble.
This motherfucker's got a squeeze and he's got to fight those handoffs.
Gotta fight those hands off.
Oh Nice knee on the brake.
You feel that clamp.
Those guys are really good gear teen.
Like you could see it when they clamp onto dude's like whoa.
Like 'em honey ya ya.
You ever see that guy fight honey?
I Yaz is tiny gentlemen.
He didn't mean,
I think he used to fight at one 35 now he's won 25 right?
Isn't honey at one 30 the one 35 or one 25 [inaudible] not the biggest guy in
the world.
Find out what way it is.
I think he's a flyweight.
Now.
I might be wrong,
but anyway,
it doesn't look like a bodybuilder or anything.
Oh,
dos Anjos caught him with that left high kick and that's what I'm talking about.
Like he can,
he can add in.
Yeah.
Oh,
Jesus.
Oh Jesus.
Fucking Christ.
Fucking Christ Jesus.
Oh Jesus.
He's going to win Jesus fucking Christ.
Oh my God.
Jesus.
Yeah,
this is fucking tremendous.
Look at them again.
This is hard against,
fuck.
Joe Rogan is fucking home
down like this.
Oh Geez.
It control.
Oh yeah,
but you don't know where he is.
He doesn't know where he is.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know who he is.
This is hard.
I'm gets fucking scowl cuff.
Sakis I been waiting,
put his bucket pipe,
but three fucking months.
This is what I'm talking about.
This is what the fucking problem is.
The body,
every once in a while you run into a brick.
Fuck the wall.
This Guy Diaz the fuck could they did these people sat looking at,
Shit,
you got to kill this motherfucker.
It's fucking over.
There's a new one 55 where it's to McGregor.
Now,
where's Conor McGregor now?
This text.
Philadelphia.
You don't talk mother the pockets.
Eddie Alvarez.
This is crazy.
I told you this is the pilot a bucket here.
You fucking Momos holy shop with your bullshit and mark fucking hot.
She stopped compared to this.
God Damn
God Damn Eddie Alvarez.
I told you I was excited when you called me.
This is the fucking fighter he had suckers.
Holy Shit.
Eddie Alvarez.
She says,
I've got an anxiety attack.
He looks fantastic.
It's what I'm fucking talking about.
That was spectacular,
man.
150 rounds.
Joe Rogan fucking spectacular.
Look at this.
Boom.
That right hand landed there.
The the legs go.
Oh Shit.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
See again.
Wham.
O He snuck it in right over the guard.
Oh,
we did the chicken dance.
I'll tell you what dos Anjos.
He weathered a fucking dollar stores.
No nothing for those sign.
Use a fucking savage to Conor McGregor.
You better pack eight lunches if you want to fuck with these motherfuckers.
These motherfuckers cheese.
This is the deck five.
Oh my God,
Eddie Alvarez,
look at these common
enemy America.
Fuck you when you're dumped.
Fight smart contradictions,
but the pocket,
wow.
This was at Joe Rose boy,
Mark Henry.
That guy is one of the best coaches in MMA today.
Dude from New Jersey.
Suck my Dick.
You walk when you're fucking machines and your bullshit.
I'm paid some fucking dude.
Suck my Dick.
And his other client was Frankie Edgar,
but heart,
they show up with nothing but heart.
And I'm a big fan of Henry's big fan.
Fucking tremendous
winner by Tko new one 50 are you fucking kidding me?
And he just throws a tremendous wrench into everything now.
Well,
you know what else it does?
It lets everybody know how fucking Goddamn good Michael Chandler and I told you
on the phone,
Joel broke and he came in,
he looked through bots.
The first fight he bugged Gilbert,
the other guy.
All the first five is a slow fucking starter.
It's over now.
Well,
the first fight,
a lot of pressure.
First of all,
you know,
first fight in the UFC,
he's careers online,
you know,
leaves Bella tour as a champion,
but it shows you how good do you see how good Michael Chandler looked in his
last fight?
They,
these two had wars over in Bellator wars and Chandler,
uh,
just knocked out pit bull in the first round.
Tam Eddie Alvarez looked good.
I looked fucking tremendous.
I've got an anxiety attack.
Joe Rohde.
What's my God,
what we're saying like the Eddie Alvarez is the kind of guy says occasion.
This is,
this is the shit we forgotten.
There's no,
you'll see tattoos on him or a goat p and whatnot.
That twos
motherfucker fucking hot.
Then the animal man,
he hits hard to look at that.
Boom.
Oh Shit.
Dos Anjos took some Nah,
they'll sign.
Yes.
Oh my God.
Was anybody else would have went down by now.
20 guys would have went down by now.
Fucking Eddie Alvarez.
He's a good dude.
Just thanking the people who train them.
Look at this great guy,
man.
Good for him,
good for him,
and great for the sport to Greg.
Great Guy.
Great for the sport.
Really Likable Guy.
Really marketable guy.
Good for him.
Good for him,
man.
You know what dose on Joe,
so he'll be back.
Now that sets up some interesting though,
that being y'all,
I now you got this,
this,
this throws a monkey wrench into everything,
but you ain't beating this kid.
You Ain't beating this kid for the next two or three fights.
Alvarez.
Yeah,
you ain't beating him.
This kid's a fucking Philadelphia guy.
He's believing pizza for 20 years.
He's done.
You're going to give him a lobster tail.
Docking lights out,
lights out.
I wonder if he gets a number and Madoff gets a shot at him next.
I wonder if that's what they set up.
You know?
Uh,
it's hard to deny.
Nijmegen Madoff his shot.
He's undefeated and he's the number one contender to show real.
But this is beautiful.
What a beautiful right hand.
He snuck it in there,
man.
And he saw him do that chicken dance.
That's crazy that he didn't go down,
man.
No,
no,
no.
And you count the punches.
He got hit with,
Oh,
this is fucking Carlos condit jr he got hit with bombs.
He's just teeing off on him.
Herb Dean best in the business right there and just looks at,
he's like,
Yep,
I seen enough.
I've seen enough and I totally agree.
Perfect.
Time to stop at Herb Dean is the best.
He really is.
Who you're breathing heavy cheeses.
You okay with that?
I was getting anxiety though.
For Real.
Yeah.
Cause you get worked up.
I love this shit.
This is my life.
But I love it's my business.
I saw hot dog.
This is hard.
That was hard.
That's hard dog.
That's not,
what do you think?
You're hanging out with your boys and drinking non gluten and he fucking look at
this tomorrow,
man.
Look at the prelim.
Just the prelims.
Cat Zingano and Julianna Pena.
Johnny Hendricks and Calvin Gaslamp,
j Dilla,
Sha Allah.
Sun's out and sage Northcutt and Enrique.
Man,
there ain't a dime on that card.
Jamie.
Look at the fucking Johnny Hendricks gas domain.
What does that,
uh,
is that even money?
Yeah.
But they're all pretty much,
even Frankie Yag is even now,
there ain't a dime on this car.
If you look at and make a dime,
you better fucking bet baseball this weekend because this is,
um,
I got to look at the Friday early card.
Look at us,
look at the main,
oh my goodness.
I make a dollar on this.
Look at the organ.
The Bet Travis Browne is another dog and he should,
Tate is now the main fight.
That's the main fight.
Now that's the headline and fight.
And we should take an Amanda Nunez.
Very interesting.
Look at this.
Joe Rogan.
Tj Dillashaw minus four 10.
I can't make a dime,
but look at that.
That card,
that's,
that seems like they decided to have Nesha versus Amanda Nunez over Brock Lesnar
versus,
is that true?
Yeah.
So they switched that up because just before that.
Yeah,
just looking at what's opposite.
Somebody made an executive decision.
Well,
they look at embedded.
They still hold a bikini.
Huh?
That's basically is fuck
this shit.
That's probably what it is.
She should be.
Well,
it might be,
she might be the best one to sell this card.
Yeah,
but also like from a hardcore fan standpoint,
you got to go,
how the fuck is all doe in Edgar for the title?
Not even talked about?
That's,
I mean it's an interim title.
It is an interim belt,
right?
I mean that's what's going on.
Yeah.
Interim featherweight title,
but it is for the belt.
You know what I mean?
Obviously Conor McGregor is going to have a hard fucking time making one 55 one
one 45 again.
I mean I guess he could do it,
but how much more is he going to do that
after you saw this tonight?
Yeah,
that one 55 and the be hell's kitchen dog.
He knows he's going to want to fight these guys.
Would you?
Yeah.
It kind of wants to fight those guys.
That's where the money is to that kid.
Not only can he throw punches,
but that kid could wrestle to that.
Fuck yeah.
Alvarez is a very good restaurant and that's how he beat Pettis itch all over
down there and I'm on us.
He's got to come home now and killed Diaz because what he's turning his back to
is the fucking hell is dead.
It's,
it's the original room on a Tuesday.
You can't,
there's six people there.
There's six people that you got those two savages at one 45 and then you got,
now you got this fucking Philadelphia Kid.
You've got the Brazilian,
you got the fucking Russian boom.
Who else is at one 55 linger and know that Max Holloway kid?
No,
he's 45.
Well,
those kids will live out.
The other kid that you talked about that stayed at one fifth,
the uh,
Dustin poray.
What's the point?
You got to hell's kitchen down it now.
So the UFC just got,
it's a tremendous weight class.
Damn.
Alvarez was throwing bombs.
No,
no,
no.
I feel that pain going on by look.
I mean,
these are like full count.
These Jamie,
you count these.
He got it fucking Han.
I'm a bunch of time.
Boom.
I mean full windups significant strikes.
57 50 fucking seven.
He landed 57 looking at,
Huh?
Oh,
and you've got no coke.
Oui.
Oh,
look at that.
Total strikes and significant strikes.
Look,
all of it strikes were significant Rogan Michael,
she has his number 10 looking at and row.
Oh,
what are you saying,
Jamie?
That might not be perfectly updated,
but what the mouse just because they're both the same.
Yeah,
but that means he just hit him every time hard while I was a significant strikes
and strikes.
They can be the same thing.
The fight before with Roy Nelson and Lewis and the more different from the stats
on here.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
That's interesting.
Okay.
Who is Joe Rogan?
Huh?
So it might not be updated.
Yeah,
they're showing you right there when he was setting this up.
Now making Madoff is a beast,
man.
Well,
I mean he's been the number one contender for a long time and he's a very
skillful man.
Very skillful,
very strong.
If he can get through camp and be healthy,
but that's a significant if,
because he's pulled out a couple times now and had pretty significant
injuries.
No one's a bigger fan of that dude than me.
I think he's a,
he's one of the biggest puzzles.
The one of the most difficult puzzles to solve.
And the division Amy supposed to fight Tony,
but,
um,
they had,
uh,
they had to postpone that fight,
so it'd be,
I was one of the best fights I've ever seen Tony had to pull out at due to an
injury.
Right.
Tony got injured lung infection or yeah,
lots of something.
And that's when that young man who,
uh,
what was his name,
who just fought number Grumet off the young guy who took the fight on real short
notice.
And uh,
this motherfucker had just gotten like surgery on his elbow like a six weeks ago
or some crazy shit.
It might've been less than that.
He's nuts.
Yeah.
Darrell Horcher,
that guy's a stud,
took that fight against Dharma Madoff.
Nobody wanted that fight.
Took that fight on short notice and fought well fought real well,
especially for a guy would just merely didn't have any time to prepare for it.
But I think that Norma Madoff needed that fight too.
He needed a fight against a guy that may not,
you know,
first fight in the UFC.
You might not have been a,
I'm just teasing.
Sally's quoting,
you'll excuse me.
It might not have been as well prepared.
You know,
I think that a normal gromit off probably need to knock the dust off a little
bit.
He's out for two years.
Two years with injuries.
Man.
That's just one ACO.
Lot of shit wrong.
He got hurt again.
Yep.
Same knee got hurt twice.
Yeah.
I think he might've rushed is a comeback sometimes guys do that guy,
a lot of guys had done that.
They uh,
they hurt their knee.
And then in the process of rehabbing it,
short fuse,
Herman did that hurt.
It was rehabbing it.
Um,
started training again.
Blew it out again.
Um,
Capa guys,
I've had that happen
dog.
I'm still overwhelmed by that site.
I'm still overwhelmed.
Incredible.
Like my head can't even rent my,
I can't believe it had a funny fucking feeling too.
I was like,
you know what man,
this is the battle right here.
This is going to be a great fucking fight.
Yeah.
But you know,
we weren't in fucking Vegas to better.
So who gives a fuck,
Jamie?
And if we were,
I would have bet you would've been on Ebay.
Yeah.
Just a yard stick.
Just to watch the fucking fight.
You got to give the kid the benefit of doubt.
That's one of the greatest lines in any movie.
When the loan shark gives rocky 500 and it goes,
you don't have to pay me back.
I think lady luck as in your colon.
I kept hearing that all fucking week,
lady La kids.
Fuck on man.
I love all that shit.
That's,
that's how much of an underdog was he?
Not much and a half to one.
That's it.
It wasn't this no doll.
That's amazing.
No double have thrown a yard stick just to watch and have assaulted.
There's no doubt as we go.
Vegas took such a bat on Nate Diaz that now they tightened their lines on
fucking Vegas when they'd be as did that.
They paid out hundreds of thousands and they said,
fuck it.
That's it.
No more mistakes with this.
They got [inaudible].
They got everybody in on it helping out with the lines.
Now there's no more mistakes.
For a long time.
You see week lines,
you know you want to bet football and make money,
go shit.
If you lose the September,
you're a fucking loser.
You Bet.
Basketball the first three weeks in November,
you're going to win the lines a week home.
The next home on a Tuesday night,
they give him three.
Come on,
they're going to run away with,
you know,
Shit like that.
That's common sense shit.
But then they tightened their shit up.
Come December.
Same thing happened.
You know when I first you should go to your,
we use ago just in my thought,
not even what you would say to me.
I would win money than the first fight.
I have a bet with Sean shirt against Frankie.
I was just sick and tired.
They go on.
I could have made money this weekend cause the lines were dog shit.
You would talk to me on the plane about generalities and I'd watched
generalities and I was a fucking dummy and I'd put it together.
Can you imagine somebody who knew the game,
like somebody who was a fighter,
you could've killed Vegas early.
Now,
I think after Diaz,
whatever.
Cause I always look,
I always look at some of my blood,
I gotta look,
but after the gas there's no more mistakes.
And then they used to have a lot of mistakes in the undercards because listen,
you're going to gamble to make money.
If you want to be with Beanie,
you might as well go get it.
Your palm read.
That's not gambling.
Gambling is to make money and to put your,
your percentage is higher than make a fucking living.
So it doesn't matter what I bet.
Well,
I had,
Ronda doesn't really fucking mad if you had Holly Holm because some idiot in
Tennessee bet 200,000 on the opening fight that nobody looked at because he knew
that the fucking,
you know what has been some times where we brought in guys where I look at the
line and uh,
I know who they were and I know how good they were and I'd be like,
this line is crazy.
Yeah.
They don't know.
There's been a no meeting five times.
Nobody really knows.
But you also have a thing in the UFC calls first time jitters.
The crowd grow show,
you don't really know how to judge it.
There's some guys you know,
won't get first round genders.
There's a certain,
there's a certain level of God that operates at such a professional level that
they're pretty much always operate at that level.
It's weird.
He kind of,
you can kind of guess when guys won't get UFC jitters.
It's real weird,
man.
I can't guess.
You got good.
I can,
I don't know where they're coming from and what organization.
There's only a few guys.
We haven't got the far with them.
So Alster didn't get UFC jitters at all at all.
And when he came to the UFC,
uh,
it was when,
you know,
drug testing was a little bit their phone.
That's right.
But he watched that Brock fight.
Oh,
you fucking,
he just kicked him right in the fucking side.
But not only that,
that was his first fight in the UFC.
So everybody's waiting to see him and I've been waiting to see him forever.
So you know,
I'm a big kickbox and fan and he was the k one Grand Prix champion as I've
watched this kickboxing matches with Badr Hari and go con Saki and I mean he's a
worldclass kickboxer so I was like if this guy can keep people off often there's
a lot of people that are fucked because this is a,
you're going to see some stupid high
level striking.
I mean his striking,
it's very clean man.
Real dangerous.
Especially when he was jacked.
We were super Overeem Uber Him.
He's one of those guys man.
So like his for when when I saw him fight in the UFC,
I'm like this guy's not going to have first round jitters.
It's not going to have first fight jitters.
He's just fought too many times.
It's fun.
Prides for dreams want k one was the Strikeforce heavyweight champion.
He was a dream heavyweight and he's not going to get,
he's not going to get rattled.
It might.
That was his first wife.
I mean he might lose.
You just came in and went for that fucking stomach.
Played that victim pulled out fight.
Find them.
Find the Brock Lesnar.
Alastar Overeem fight.
Cause that I just want to look it over him to body real quick because when that
guy,
is it a,
it's on fight pass,
right?
Yeah.
You can find it on fight pass.
I'm sure the stream has ended.
Thank you for watching.
God Damn Eddie Alvarez.
Congratulations.
You fucking savage.
Is there a um,
you know,
we've got to get dude,
we got to get the new apple TV cause this old apple TV is dog shit compared to
the new one.
The new one's bad.
Oh,
the new one.
They liked that hawk.
They were Redman bands.
I wouldn't buy it,
but red band has it is dope.
How much is,
I don't know.
Apple Watch.
Oh you
boy.
It's after 100 Brock versus Overeem.
Uh,
I wouldn't say it's more than one at one 41.
There it is.
Wow.
Yeah.
Six foot five two 56 versus six foot three two 65.
They let me tell you something.
They both way to 65 cause I,
I remember with them weighing in.
I don't think Allister wade a hair under like two 60 they're both like the same
weight.
I think God,
it's hard to remember.
Yeah.
See this,
this thing is whack of dishes.
The new one you can kind of,
okay,
I'll do it.
The new one you swipe your finger across.
He could pick a point.
It's got like a swipe pad on it.
Just like a,
you're a keypad on your laptop is that kind of thing.
The new one's dope and you can talk into it.
Joey Diaz,
what?
You can talk into your,
your eye,
apple TV remote.
Tell what you want to watch.
Like what's up shit.
What was that movie that you were in?
The one that saved Christmas that you were in a series of the dog and saved
Christmas.
By the way.
I told you before,
I will tell you again,
my kids love that fucking movie.
They love it.
They still watching love it.
Especially the six year olds,
just like eight of them.
They love us like eight of those fucking movies.
They loved that.
That's Joey.
Joey's been over here.
They just like,
they love it.
They love seeing you on TV.
They laugh,
they think it's so funny.
Those are fun movies,
man.
I don't remember what my point was.
What was I gonna say?
Pull them up with your voice on that.
So I could say the dog to saved,
I'd say an into the remote and it would find it finds,
it just shows up on uh,
the uh,
the screen and you're like,
Yep,
that's it.
You talk to the thing.
Yeah,
you do.
You talk to it.
It does searches within in the God damn future.
Joey Diaz.
So strange.
Strange time to be alive.
So we're fast four in this thing until we get to the Brock Lesnar.
Alistair Overeem,
slug fest.
So like,
that's a guy that I didn't think was going to have a hard time competing in the
UFC.
Tim Kennedy,
that's another one.
When he came over to the UFC and my people have been shooting at him and
Afghanistan for years,
he's not going to get rattled coming into the UFC.
He was fine.
Luke Rockhold same thing.
There's like a bunch of guys where you just knew they were going to be fine.
Lorens Larkin,
he's another one.
Robbie Lawler,
when he came back to the UFC,
he's not going to get rattled at all.
You know Robbie Lawler is as savage as they come.
That dude,
there's like no pure expression of like primal combat.
Then like his fights with Johny Hendricks,
the second fight in particular and his fight with Rory Macdonald.
Just blood and guts and it's Carlos condit fight both those guys just blood and
guts like fuck.
Got It here.
See where we're at here.
Two 31 and 27 seconds in here.
Is Our internet still dog shit aim Jamie.
Uh,
it's gotten any better.
Wow.
Look,
the fight is this.
This is a long ass time ago.
It doesn't seem like it has one 41 but there's 60 UFC is,
I go almost in Gambia region.
I got to move this up a little bit here.
So a Joey d is,
where are you doing your Special Chicago?
Oh Shit.
Rosemont xannies Oh shit.
Blue collar.
Like a motherfucker like a motherfucker.
After my storage where I started full time training only I sets,
you know I'm going to go fucking commando him till he does.
I got to go GSP and the routes.
I got a coach.
I've got everything old school.
You got to calm any coach?
Yeah.
Who'd you call me?
Coach Red Fox.
How's he helping you?
I don't know.
From the grave.
He talked to Eddie Griffin to the bathroom at the comedy store.
That's
something that's up to my fucking house with some chickens though.
Saying something.
Do you remember that?
Come on.
I'll never forget that horrible fucking scene.
Even though the movie was,
that movie was ridiculous.
It was hilarious.
I love movies like that.
Foolish ways.
My,
that's my personal roadhouse brother.
I remember his name was foolish waste.
Which yeah,
that would be green light.
The Red Light.
It was different.
Whatever.
Some with the light areas you thought I forgot it.
Shit.
That was a master p production.
Oh look at Nate Diaz.
It looks like a young boy here.
Nate Diaz winner by unanimous decision.
He looks so young.
So now Overeem is standing in the in the cage.
This is weird.
They're showing Nate Diaz backstage while Overeem is fighting about to fight
Brock Lesnar.
I don't understand what's going on here.
Oh,
okay.
The Brock Lesnar fight.
I pat fast forwarded through it.
Woopsies
so,
um,
are you self producing this thing?
No.
Your special wave,
uh,
whose,
which is a,
what's new wave?
They did all the little specials.
I did a bunch of specialists that did Thompson goes
um,
this,
this doesn't make any sense.
I feel like the Manny Gambier and fight,
they might've showed it afterwards.
It doesn't make sense.
Yay.
Maybe it is.
Maybe that's what it was.
Yeah.
Must be the Manny gambler and fight.
It must've been a fight that they showed after the main event.
The main event happens.
Quick minutes left.
What?
We always do that,
which is actually kind of cool.
Then you get to see some of the prelims,
some of the excellent prelim fights.
All right,
so we're going to take this back to two hours in.
That's probably when the fight took place.
So they did Thompson girls too.
Is that what you said?
Yeah,
they did a bunch of people.
They did Ali Wong.
I heard Ali Wong,
uh,
at the comedy store the other night.
She was fucking hilarious dog.
She's always hilarious.
She's hilarious.
And when she was pregnant up there,
when she was ready to bust,
she just her special.
When she was pregnant,
she was killing me.
One night on a Sunday night,
I went down there and she went up white two before me.
I went to Blackstone to the gills and she said some shit that my fucking jaw
dropped.
I couldn't stop laughing.
It's her delivery,
her voice.
She's got that shit down to a science man.
She got the,
he's very good.
They're the size of that motherfucker back then.
God Damn Uber Dream.
It was a ridiculously big back then.
Here we go.
So you fucking eaten.
You're shooting,
you eat and a boat.
What are you doing to get that big dog?
Him?
Yeah.
You're doing,
Geez.
Is this jeans a big part of his,
his jeans.
You're doing people you're doing fucking doing.
You're doing viking come.
That's where you're doing fucking out of.
You're eating the fucking 16 eggs for breakfast,
but all that stuff is not going to give you that bone structure or
that bone structures insane.
I mean,
he's built like a fucking shaved down gorilla.
There's no one built that guy.
I mean,
that is one of the biggest athletes you ever going to see in the heavyweight
division.
Both of these guys.
Yeah.
Both these guys,
these guys.
Now this is pre Uber.
This is Uber.
This is Uber aim.
This is when you look at the size of him.
He's fucking Jack Modified here watching the,
when they um,
he's got lane,
must be 63.
There it goes.
Alster way to 63 broccoli to 66.
It's fucking crazy.
That's so heavy.
He's got to cut weight to make two 66 two it was like cool Brock fucking mood
and he's way bigger than two 66.
He's huge.
He probably weighs two 80 to 85 I bet he cuts.
I wouldn't be surprised if at some point in time he cut as much as 25 get that
bay and he's been playing football.
They life.
They just developed this wild quickness.
Cho,
they don't play baseball growing up.
They throw that fucking thing at track and we'll,
have you ever seen his combine numbers?
No.
They're ridiculous.
Come on other crazy.
Oh yeah.
He's an elite athlete.
Like is a vertical leap long jump amount of times he can bench press 225 pounds
or something.
It was like 50 or something ridiculous.
He's one of those guys.
He's a freak.
I mean,
yeah.
Let's see what his combine numbers are.
What do this,
he did a 40 and 47 come on,
man.
He's got a 10 foot standing broad jump,
35 inch vertical leap
and his bench and squat numbers are ridiculous.
[inaudible] can Seikos 40 to 25 say that again.
30 Times he bends to 25 Jesus Christ.
30 Times.
If he did a four,
seven what did Conseco do?
Yeah.
Conseco was like fucking four,
four really?
Let's see.
Oh fuck it go.
That's 40 basis.
That's something that at that size you can't do that shit.
You gotta write 40 Jamie.
It's been the 40
you don't think he ran it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They had it.
They had us,
he claimed,
oh,
he claimed he claimed he cleaned.
Well,
listen bro,
but he's a serious athletes.
Look at the 40 40 club.
Okay.
Just hit that.
That's what tells you how many of you,
how many people in the 40 40 club.
You know,
there's not a lot of people in that job.
He was,
that was that Jose Conseco.
This is what I'm telling you that to get that you have to be fast.
And three of the three of those people
were accused of certain things.
Yeah,
all of them.
But probably did it.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if Alfonso Soriano,
but how many in all the baseball,
there's only been four 44 forties
here we go.
Look at this.
Okay.
The size of that motherfucker,
and again,
this is like,
I don't even think it was a year after Brock Lesnar had some serious surgery and
his stomach,
they removed like 12 inches of his colon.
Right?
Well,
it's not just the size of Alster,
but Al's dirt is highly skillful as a striker and just as big as Brock.
So lucky he's got the horsepower to keep them off of him and his striking is
just fucking elite.
And so all he has to do is take his time,
stay on the outside like he's doing right now,
way for those openings.
And then when he finds a make the most out of them and you see like it just
slips away from that Jab.
Like you ain't going to hit him that easy.
He's going to hang on.
The outside is not going to charge at you.
Look at Nice counter,
right hand season common counters.
Super Dangerous to strike with this guy.
He's so clever because like he's had some knockout losses.
He's a human being.
I mean if a guy like Ben Rothwell catches him,
he's going to go out.
Everybody goes out.
But when you watch him knockout junior dos Santos and you see how he set that
up,
caught him with that left upper cut.
You realize how God damn good he is.
He's sneaky.
Yeah.
And who did it?
I asked her just beat was Dosantos his last fight.
I feel like it wasn't.
No,
I don't think it wasn't,
but neither of his body fucking
thank you.
The power to the body.
He stopped Lawsky,
right?
Yeah.
Well seeing the them look at boom,
run lessons.
This is going right,
but a bread basket.
Yeah.
What's also these?
You fuck them up?
Shots are so powerful.
He's his technique.
His Moitai,
his knees to the body in particular.
There's so devastating.
He's like one of the best ever in the heavyweight division for throwing knees to
the body without kicks at them.
Right back to watch WWE,
but still left kick watch.
We slipped.
His left kick walking.
He said,
you can see that on his face as he was going down.
Fuck this shit.
Wait to move back to rehearsal.
He sets up this switch.
Kick to the body right here.
There's a moment where Brock is throwing the right hand and ouster slips the
left kick underneath it.
No problem.
Boom.
Look at that knee.
Oh Shit.
No.
That ain't even hit though.
That's not it,
but no,
that was it.
He was,
here comes a kick.
Boom.
There it is.
That's it right there.
That's it.
Boom.
It was that kick,
that left power kick.
Okay,
backup.
I've got,
uh,
that left kick is a thing
of beauty,
man.
But you know what,
Joe here and I'm way before that he was,
you could see it on Brock's face,
bro.
No,
he certainly did.
But he was getting,
boom,
there it is.
He was doing nothing but hurt.
No Allister,
that house,
that version announced or when the scariest guys ever still is rocky was like,
fuck this shit.
What do you think about him and Steve Bay?
What's your thoughts on that fight?
Because you're going to be there.
It's going to be a great fucking fight.
You know,
this guy's kickboxing is so advanced,
more than steel.
Steve Bay,
you think so?
This guy spinning in Phuket,
Thailand and Bangkok and the jungles of debt.
Winkled John's,
you know,
it's a different,
it's a different type of fighter.
I mean,
I'm not saying that I'm not taking anything away from her dorm or anything.
Uh,
I had a feeling he was going to knock fucking,
we're doing mouth.
Really.
I had a feeling,
I just had a feeling he wanted it.
He wanted to live Joe.
He wanted it,
he wanted it.
And those types of guys are fucking,
uh,
you know,
so boom.
Now you've got this,
this guy,
and they're doing it in Cleveland,
but this guy has experienced,
you know,
if he's at Winkeljohn,
one thing about Winkle,
John's,
those guys know how to put together a game plan man.
And if you stick through it,
I guarantee the percentages are high.
They put together a gate,
a great game plan.
I'm not taking nothing away from the hope it's coach and nothing.
I'm just saying that winkled that's what they specialize in.
Joke game plan.
And then they practice it and they fucking,
uh,
and sometimes it works against them with homes.
Ameesha tape,
but it worked with homes and Ron and work with Carlos conduit and the Diaz Guy.
It works.
They,
if you stick to that game plan,
you'll succeed.
Jon Jones,
you know,
so who knows what they got in store for this kid?
Well,
the way I look at his house,
there's always a threat.
He's just so skillful.
As a striker.
But when I see what Steve Bay did,
the Fabio Maldonado who obviously he's a smaller guy,
um,
but you know,
just had a war with fade or do you see that fight you got a couple of weeks ago
not to fade or down?
Kinda got fucked.
Lots of decision should have been dry I think.
Um,
but either way,
at the end of the day,
uh,
Steve Bay looked like a murderer or against our Lawsky crushed our Lawsky
knocks.
We're doing mountain the first round,
man.
It's hard to,
uh,
hard to look past that.
Well,
I'm looking at those times,
that perspective,
that fucking mirror is,
it's confidence is out the fuck.
You know,
he said he was gonna knock out Bruh.
Don't he said it.
You know,
so right now this confidence is high.
It's in his backyard.
W who knows?
All I know is right now,
I feel this is a fucking war.
This is going to be a really good fucking fight.
Look at that knee to the body.
Good Lord.
Yeah.
Steve Bay's a tank man.
He's a legit tank and he's a serious fucking athlete too.
Man.
Works hard,
real talented,
stays cool under pressure.
So a murder when he gets in there,
man,
so calm,
like that guy can fight at his very best now,
especially now with all of his experience inside the octagon he get,
he's like,
he's like seasoned.
You know what I'm saying?
I learned about Winkeljohn when I watched
GSPS coach do the breakdown of the Holly Holm.
Ronda,
that was possibly one of the best breakdowns.
I saw him more ways than one.
I learned so much from that breakdown from what the I at the house doesn't have
a clue what the fuck you're doing to people at home.
Don't have a clue what the fuck that,
oh,
they're watching.
But what do you mean?
Like the way he was?
Uh,
you know why she was keeping a hips high?
Just little things.
I didn't know.
I never even fucking heard of this shit.
It's just little things and the for them,
for Holly homes to be that good at it,
that meant that Winkeljohn and the other guy,
Greg Jackson,
Professor Greg Jackson put this thing together and they drilled that thousands
and thousands and thousands and thousands and thousands of time.
So I tell you,
Joe Rogan,
every time you feel this hand on your hip,
you put your ass up.
We're going to do that a thousand times.
I'm gonna come to your house and every time I touch it yet I want you to drop
your knees and she can't throw you.
You know,
just simple shit.
I like preparation.
The preparation that Holly Holm had for Rhonda was fucking money was money and
yeah,
Rhonda was consumed with other things,
but I was very impressed with that.
The preparation Carlos had against,
uh,
against Diaz.
You know,
nobody thought going to stay in there against the ass.
Nobody fucking even came close to that.
And,
um,
I learn something.
I was like,
wow,
I fucking learned a lot that night about preparation,
how they prepared for this.
So I liked that camp for that.
You know,
everybody,
every camp has a different thing.
Aka everybody accuses him of being like these fucking,
they go to bras,
you know Jim Brawls and shit.
You know,
I grew up in the 70s Joe Rogan.
I thought that that was what was acceptable.
Yeah,
well a lot of people don't now.
I still do.
I mean it's still good still.
It's an argument.
You know,
the problem with this whole conversation is no one's wrong.
like Eddie Alvarez was right.
He did 150 rounds and it prepared them perfectly and he went in and took,
those aren't just the only one.
So he walked into that fight with two black eyes,
Joey.
I mean that guy sparring some fucking hard rounds.
Probably having some Jim more.
So in his case it worked out.
And when I say 150 rounds,
do I get Joe Rogan to duplicate Rafael dos Anjos style.
You get a bunch of different guys usually,
and I prepare for dosign Yossi style pay for guys mimicking.
Three would joke with him go red banned them that throw Brian in there,
throw Eddie.
And so it's three guys at all mimicking Dosantos,
one facing different guys,
most likely in a good camp.
They would want you to try to mimic some of the movements so you get all hand
up.
I'm getting set up for this so I know exactly how to react to it.
That's well,
Mark Henry,
who was his striking coach is a very skillful guy.
We're going to go eat pizza.
They are the risks.
Let's do it.
I liked that car.
I heard his pizza is fantastic.
It's got to be in an area where you can't fucking camp corral.
You can go Joe,
shoot you.
So he's gotta be a good boxer.
Yeah,
I've had some conversations about food with him.
He seems legit as fuck.
I never met him.
I never saw him saying he's a great guy.
You'd love him.
But uh,
his um,
his strategy and his,
uh,
his understand his tactical understanding of like striking movements and
combinations.
I'm always very impressed,
very impressed by the training and very impressed by what Brendan Schaub term
told me because Brendan shop did some work with them for like one camp and he
said the dude had like fucking notebooks filled with all these different notes
about different movements and recreating stuff and drills and all the stuff that
we're going to work on and what to do in this and they have different codes for
stuff and they change them all the time.
Like five,
six,
seven hit him with the two,
three,
five like it's all like these codes that they create apparently like it.
He doesn't want anybody pattering patterning it so they change it up.
This is what Sean was telling me,
shop shop was super impressed with them and Shabazz was like,
look,
if the dude didn't live on the other side of the country,
I would definitely trained when looking at who guy he showed up with this guy
who meet him.
Just get up.
He had Frankie,
I go for three.
Edson Barboza.
You had him for a long time as well.
The guy obviously knows what the fuck he's doing and his,
his striking work with his students is very,
it's very high level.
Barboza is obviously Barbara is a fucking freak.
I mean his striking so God damn good.
Especially his kicks are just ridiculous.
God Damn,
he's good now.
You know it was just on fire right now.
He's another hundred 55 pounder on
that barter was ro one 55 who did buy Bose is just beat.
Wait,
you got to hit me with this after I eat it because I'm trying to remember
because it was just stunning.
Um,
beautiful.
He was beautiful.
That fight.
Yeah.
Who the fuck did he beat Anthony Pettis.
That's right.
Yeah.
That was a fight where pedis finally got a guy who wanted to strike with them.
You know,
because Pettis has been getting these guys like Dolson Joe Send Eddie Alvarez
who could grab a hold of them and squish them,
push him against the fence,
use their physical strength and the wrestling.
And that was like a guy that he,
that was the,
exactly the kind of fight that he wanted and it just didn't work out because
that's how good Barboza is.
He's on the fastest kickers in the sport.
Perfect technique too.
But that,
that's,
you know,
that's him.
He's very good.
He was good going in there,
but a lot of it,
you got a credit to Mark Henry and what he's done with Frankie to one of the
most impressive like Beaton's I was seeing was one that I was switching the
challenge and I saw Jose Aldo.
I didn't know nothing about no w eat nothing at all.
Wec only getting the fuck out of the UFC and they have to sell a fucking league.
Now I got to watch this shit,
but I saw him.
The reason why I stopped was I just saw,
he's like cakes and then the next day we got on a plane and you would talk to me
about it and I didn't know what to say.
Like I was fucking,
those leg kicks was something I had never seen before.
Yeah,
he's pretty pretty.
God Damn sporty.
He throws bombs,
man,
he um,
at one point in time,
I guess when he was young he was a really high level soccer player and a like
maybe even had aspirations of going pro.
I could have possibly been at that level if he decided to go that path and
instead went to Jujitsu and MMA obviously,
but a hit because of that,
I think those years of running and sprinting and throwing,
kicking soccer balls,
he just,
he whips those kicks man.
They're devastating.
Ooh.
His fight with Frankie and his fight with a Uriah is protected.
That's the one I saw.
Oh my God.
It's really weird that you were posting shit a couple of weeks ago by Ian trying
to turn you on to soccer the 70s we just didn't dig soccer socket influence this
bigass yeah.
Again,
I'm going back to the flutes.
No flutes.
I didn't know.
I didn't even fucking know.
I was called up in the 70s you like the Pittsburgh Steelers.
You like this shit.
You play two hand touch and one day some dude that my mother's boss like you
want to play football?
Like we ain't going to go to eight Hudson county park the tomorrow at night.
I go up there with my football.
These guys playing soccer to me he was like fucking a different language.
Like we just didn't grow up in that.
It didn't become popular in this country to like 85 84 they started introducing
it and schools and stuff.
My high school soccer game,
I didn't know none of my mind.
Dude.
Pele I knew pay later.
That's it.
That's all I knew about bucking soccer.
That's all everybody knew.
That's how popular payday was.
You know he's like the Tony Hawk of soccer.
Like nobody knows anybody other than Tony Hawk.
Who's a pro skateboarder.
Tony Hawk.
That's why everybody knows who put who rides a bike professionally.
Lance Armstrong,
but I heard he did steroids.
You know like there's like a few guys that they're the only guy that anybody has
ever heard of in that genre.
Right.
Who Dives?
Greg Louganis.
That's it.
Nobody else dives.
There's no other divers.
Shut up.
Who Swims fast,
but that fucking pothead goggle Phelps,
that guy,
he's swamped fast.
Come up again.
Nobody else can't swim fast.
He's the only guy we know though.
He's about to fuck him up again.
Yeah,
like he's about to fuck him up again.
How was he doing?
Is He,
uh,
has he done any other races or is he just preparing for the Olympics?
I think he was just preparing for,
I think he's been winning.
He's been winning.
He's done a couple of races.
I don't think he's been like actually actively compared to baby in a couple of
times.
Yeah.
Maybe when you get in trouble for pot.
God,
that was stupid.
I had to apologize.
That is so fucking stupid.
They,
he could've been,
he could've had a drink in both hands and a cigar in his mouth and no one said a
word and everybody will know the kids blowing off steam.
He had an amazing Olympic career.
Think about,
look at the gold medals,
ladies and gentlemen,
think about the pressure and for relax.
Let him have his Margarita and his tobacco.
But if you catch them doing bong hits at someone's party,
like Holy Shit,
and whoever that was at narked on them should be shot in fucking hoe much.
Why don't like shit?
How dare they just didn't even know what they were doing.
Just for the fucking record.
They'll let you know that that fucking reef,
it don't even hurt your cardio.
It wasn't Michael Phelps is fucking kicking it up like that.
Swimming,
it doesn't hurt your cardio.
Those,
uh,
in extreme endurance athletes love it has been a bunch of articles written
lately on,
uh,
them taking edibles,
[inaudible] edibles and sometimes even stop at tents and vape.
They'll have like a vaporizer,
like a volcano set up halfway along the way.
The friend that took a little chill in with them on a marathon,
he stopped to Porta John and took a couple of heads.
Good for him.
Yeah.
I mean,
I bet it makes the whole thing a much better experience.
It's fucking way better for Yoga.
Bitsight some I do yoga.
I told you sober all the time.
No,
I do yoga sober all the time,
but occasionally I like to go deep and go to the hot yoga class and get my
stretch on.
Holy Shit Man.
Especially with edibles and the booze is the way to go to yoga.
You feel everything.
You can smoke 30 minutes before Yoda,
you pop a light at a bull.
I wouldn't do 800 million and you'll go to yoga.
I take 200 milligrams stretch and by the 30 minute mark at Yoga,
all that stretching and all that released,
the 200 goes to work
and it gives you a light buzz and you don't know it to,
you stuck it up position and you're breathing.
That's when you go like,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit,
you're right here.
Right?
Oh Shit.
Now I'm feeling it towards the end.
Like it's,
I used to eat banana bread and go to yoga with my wife before I knocked her up,
fucked up.
And that the only problem with yoga is you can't bring a notebook and a pen,
you know,
that's fucked up and you can't even,
you can't bring your phone because you're an asshole.
And Yoga when you're in that downward dog stone to shit that comes out of your
spine into your mind is creep.
You start looking at girls acids and the teacher and thinking about shit.
Like if there's somebody Asians in the class,
you'd rather get it.
You get all fucked up in the class.
You start thinking about green teas and shit.
You know what I thought about setting up and I might actually have to do this,
uh,
a voice activated tape recorder for inside my tank cause I don't want to leave
the tank.
No,
it's too much.
Sometimes it's too much.
Those,
those uh,
those exercises,
when you do that type of stuff,
yoga stoned when you're in that,
it kills you because you think is shit when you're in a deep stretch.
So you've never floated before.
Have,
you know,
I'm still paranoid.
I want good swimmer,
but I don't want,
you can't,
it's
Becky's going to take me to Pasadena.
That's the biggest place in the world now is it?
Yeah.
That guy that opened up that float center in Pasadena is the biggest float
center in the world.
It's the name of the company.
What's it called?
Give the give the homiest props.
I'm not sure.
I want to say it's the flow lab.
No float lab is in Venice and in a Westwood and that's the best.
This guy's got salmon,
Hollywood on the planet.
Just flow.
Just flow task.
Holly does him good for him because Becky works at all inspired by us talking
about it.
He's a good dude.
I met that guy at the Ice House in Pasadena.
It's amazing.
It'll take,
you know,
man.
Sometimes I go deep with it fucks with me for four or five days.
I like the other day I remember I dropped out of high school.
Who Remembers that shit?
Do you know?
I would remember that.
You want me to tase him?
Do you know how I went to community college?
I did two sickest part,
but without a high school diploma.
Yeah.
You could go to community college with a GED.
No,
no.
I didn't even have the GG.
He just went,
I just went.
I just started signing up.
They asked me.
I told them,
yeah,
I didn't know.
And then when I got the letter that I had too many credits,
I had to transfer the bolder.
Boulder was like,
we'd been looking for your paperwork,
we can't find your GED.
And I kept telling them it's in there and they go,
well,
ain't nothing going to get process until we have the paperwork in their hand.
So it was like a Tuesday.
I had to go take the g the other Saturday and like pass it.
My brother and I got into college.
That's how I did it.
You just bringing that up made me remember that I went to a junior college.
I literally,
I've completely forgot about it.
I forgot I fucking dropped out and got to make sure I got sad for a week.
How to cock can get dropped out of high school.
Like I was thinking like I was single for a while.
Yeah,
you were single,
you were fucking dropout.
Who the fuck wants to,
hey,
I want to drop out.
You got no future.
So you're not even thinking this when you're a high.
Recently,
three weeks ago,
I'm writing and I'm out lighting and I'm trying to figure out a hook for the
special right.
And I'm thinking about what traumatizes you right?
How can we go in all this shit they've heard and it's bullshit.
What really got to me?
And I was a member,
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I dropped out of high school,
junior year,
August,
going into senior year,
you drop out.
And I went in and like in January,
and I got my credits,
but I was three credits short to graduate and they wanted me to go to summer
school and I was like,
you know,
I ain't gonna
fuck with you.
So I didn't get to get my diploma and stands and get it,
which I didn't really care about because I had nobody to show him,
put the fucking thing.
Anyway.
So in my mind I didn't really give a fuck.
Why would I want to go to embarrass myself like sugar now I would've done it,
but then I just wanted to smoke pot and I just wanted to get out of there.
I didn't go to my graduation.
I just wanted to get out.
I felt like that whole experience was just,
it was just like,
no,
that's frustrated.
I didn't like prompts.
I didn't go to my eighth grade graduation.
I went to five star basketball camp instead.
It was one of those snow years,
so you've got to stay in school to June 29th I booked the basketball camp,
the 20th Einstein.
They went to great adventure.
Fuck that.
You know what?
I went to a good school too.
It wasn't a bad school,
but the experience,
the experience was this overwhelming pressure of becoming an adult.
That was like the big experience.
That was the scariest part of it.
More than anything,
it's just an overwhelming pressure of one day having to take care of myself and
trying to figure out what the fuck I wanted to do with my time.
High school was good for me.
I'm not going to lie.
No,
but I had a great time in high school.
Wasn't bad for me.
I had a great time taking classes.
I'll tell you what until now I think I live a couple blocks from valley college
and I always think about why don't I go there at night and take a history class?
I'm,
I'm an asshole.
Like just really learning the history class that I forgotten.
This shit just went out of my mind one day.
You know?
And it's embarrassing when people have conversations and I can't join it.
I mean,
people don't talk about history a lot around me,
but I'm just saying it's hard to get excited about a class unless you like
really thrilled with the subject.
But I'll tell you one way to learn history podcast,
podcast.
I know you've been telling me somebody else mentioned that too.
Hardcore history.
I'm Carlton fucking phenomenal.
Fucking phenomenal.
Just tune into the one I've listened to about world war one.
Okay.
Have,
you know,
I'll listen to where we'll,
we've got a whole series on world war one.
It'll blow your fucking mind.
I like what,
listen,
I didn't like reading about it.
I had a friend that was brilliant,
got arrested.
So this motherfucker was a genie,
went to Brown the whole day.
And when that we would get high at night and I asked them stupid,
creepy questions about the wars and he would break it down out Joe Diaz or break
it down.
He was from Jersey and he would say there was this fucking bar and these people.
And I understood it.
Like I finally,
when I was growing up,
I didn't really give a fuck about history man.
I didn't really give a fuck.
Somebody was saying,
well maybe uh,
you quit high school because you didn't believe in standard ally's education.
No,
I quit high school cause I was fucking bro Jack like with high school because I
had to produce something,
I had to do something and I got a warehouse job.
But Union warehouse job at mass backs century hardware.
Wow.
It was a fucking nightmare.
But I did it carrying change,
cut and change,
putting them in boxes.
Six in the morning,
the fucking six at night.
I loved the Joe Damn at that time it was a $9 an hour.
But guess what?
I have to 60 days of fucking job opened up loading trucks from seven to four and
that paid like 18 an hour.
Plus I was getting into the union and I get my benefits.
And you worked really Monday through Thursday because Friday you went home at a
quarter today cause I can still see my friends.
So I took the fucking job.
Tremendous go whenever it's seven,
nobody else there,
three other guys,
nobody talked.
I put a Walkman on with a cassette and I would just work,
everything was going great.
It's like mid December I fucking ate something and I went down every seven.
I just got sick one night and I walked off the property and I kept calling back
and then they repeat pick up the phone.
So the next day I got a call.
You got fired because you left a property even though I puked on the property
and was sick and I explained to them I really got sick.
I went home to get a different shirt cause I lived like two blocks away.
I just going to get back in and they were like,
uh,
well fi and then like a month later,
it's like mid January I go back to high school,
I'm kind of broke.
I'd go down there to get my last check and I bumped into the shop steward and I
was always smart.
Whenever I went to lunch,
I bring the shops do with a bottle he liked like JMB the pint and I'd bring them
booze.
Fuck yeah,
that's what you,
that's how you brought when he first put me in,
you were in high school?
I was in high school.
And you would give them boots.
Fuck yeah.
What's the drinking age back then?
18th 1818 but we were drinking.
I don't we,
we get,
of course in those days how we did it was we get booze delivered.
I think when I turned 18 was when the drinking age became 21 right.
So this one was it,
when was the
find out what age?
It was the scam.
In those days,
Joe Rogan was,
you weren't going to go get booze or liquor store.
You had to stand out there like a hooker trying to get some movement,
the pack of cigarettes.
So what you did was you find the liquor store had delivered.
Uh,
and then when they brought the boost,
he asked the guy would say,
fuck you mean,
what's the tab 20 I got 20 on top of it.
You're going to turn down.
Just say my grandfather sleeping.
Here's a note from my grandfather that says fucking the boosters for him.
And then we got this guy on the tab.
We would just call and we'd be on a rock.
We'd be at a park and we'd make up an address and he knew it was us.
So we'd give him an extra 20 on the top and they deliver boosty and those days,
that's a scam.
That one away.
That's interesting.
Nobody delivers booze and cigarettes no more.
And if you knew the guy that got would stop and get you us a shrimp parm
sandwich.
Listen,
you mind stopping over a Primo and get me a,
it's already called them.
They know you're coming.
I'll give you an extra five on top of the 20 guys.
Get this guy buying sandwiches for you.
People had,
I remember him,
became friends with him.
We became friends with the liquid delivery guy.
That's hilarious.
The liquor delivery guy quit that and opened up a bar really years later.
Tremendous fucking bar.
Like for six months it failed.
He started selling coke out of that and then what the fuck fucker whistle so
that they turned it.
The legal age was 21 Jamie pulled up,
uh,
at a 1984 so it was like right when I was turning 17 they turned it to 21 it was
good.
It was good for 18 that means you're drinking at 16 yeah.
When you're 18 you look 18 and 16 when I was growing up,
not to mention the New Jersey can 16 anyway.
How much everybody's drinking at 16 anything.
Anyway,
they get to a parchment.
Yeah.
When I was growing up,
you started drinking in the eighth grade.
Some guys smoked pot.
Nobody was doing hard drugs.
Now,
once that freshman summer came along,
people started falling off to the fucking wasteland,
but this was the scamp Joe Rogan.
The scam was this,
no matter where you lived in the Tristate area,
New Jersey,
if you check all the residences in New Jersey,
tons of people had New Jersey licenses.
You know why?
Why no picture?
Uh,
check and see what he had New Jersey put pictures out in la.
That was the scam.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Joe Rogan.
So Joe Rogan's got another brother,
Nigga Bro.
Oh my God.
Joe Rogan's got Nick Rogan and Mike Rogan.
Okay.
And the family.
You're ready for this one?
Joe Rogan's a hustler.
Joe Rogan steals Mick and Mike's buck and licenses south to Joey and fucking the
genius here.
They get duplicates.
What'd you ever hear Ari?
Fear Story.
What?
Ra Shit fears.
Brother fucking used his id to,
uh,
he forged his ID to get like insurance or something like that.
And Ari didn't find out until like someone called him.
He had told the story about it on the skeptic tank on his podcast.
His brother faked his ID and got his own fucking ID card.
His brother was in degenerate.
You have no idea.
You have no fucking idea with these savages,
do now.
No idea.
Yeah.
Well I didn't know that there was a,
I forgot that there was a time where id didn't have photos on them.
That's crazy.
That's hard to believe.
Do you remember the days when you didn't have to,
uh,
bring an ID to get on a plane?
Remember those days?
Oh,
fight.
I made up names.
You just get on a plane ticket and show them the ticket.
Nothing ticketed and have your name on it and nothing.
No nothing.
You could tell him John Smith and you could fly as John Smith and you could give
somebody a ticket.
You could buy a ticket and they give it to them,
but they can just go on.
I remember hiding coke in the lockers and the lockers and putting,
you know,
the ones you've got to put quarters in to get the shit out.
They don't even have those no more.
That's how long ago I traveled,
Joe and I would go to a bar and drink and go back and put $10 in quarters,
take it out to two more bumps.
That's how we're talking about it was it cost me $200 to fucking drink and do a
couple of lines in those airports.
I forgot about those locker things.
Those fucking lockers.
So that porch,
you ever been in San Francisco and you see the Yoga Room?
No.
San Francisco airport and has a yoga room?
Okay.
I didn't know if I have a yoga room was like a special fucking thing.
We need to go to do yoga next time we work San Francisco,
we need to pull in there.
It will,
it will be a long time from now since I just did the,
I was in San Francisco and 85 stuck at the airport one time and every time I
went to the bathroom I smelled the same guy in there.
And after about six hours,
eight hours,
the guy you go to pitch and also that he popped in and standing next day,
hey look at your Dick.
And then he'd go to the next guy.
So what he would do is he look at your dick going to bathroom whack off and then
he would stay in the bathroom until you took your Dick.
I went up to the thing and he was lightning quick.
He had the foot speed of a fucking 43 Conseco.
He would run the next day with his dick in his hand and smile and look.
How many times did you interact with this guy?
I didn't interact with them.
I was watching him.
You know,
I got to laugh.
If you're in the weight of it,
you're saying you got an eye for pervert.
He was like,
you're in the bathroom notch.
The Guy,
I'm stuck at a terminal.
Okay,
I'm sitting there.
The bathroom's right there.
Bathroom's right there.
There's like CNN.
It's 1985 wasn't like it is now.
My flights is 6:00 AM when I get there,
I go to the bathroom and this guy is next to me.
As I take my dick and wash my hands.
You just see what the guy looks like.
Okay.
You sit down and two hours later you see a guy going into the bathroom again.
Then three hours later you're going to send them to the bathroom again and
you'll see him walking out of that and acting suspicious and I'm like,
this is fucking crazy.
Now you're going to the bathroom again.
I'm delaying the gun.
I go in the bathroom again.
Guess who's next to me?
Got Same Guy.
You figure it out.
He's a fucking perv.
I didn't figure it out.
I never repeated this because it didn't make any sense.
I mean it was 85 there was no,
there was like a buzzer.
There was no people there and nothing.
There was like a Buzzer,
you know?
That's when you were allowed to walk to the gate.
Do you remember people,
this guy would just go to the airport and the daytime
just go jerk off and go with your coffee all fucking day at the,
well,
there's something about men's restrooms that I've always been like,
places where gay dudes hooked up.
Remember where that Senator got Troy?
It happened in San Francisco.
Yeah,
right?
Yep.
What was like a Minneapolis or something like that,
wasn't it?
They,
they used to have some weird thing they would do.
They were like,
tap their foot three times on the ground.
If you want to suck some Dick,
climb under the stalls cause stalls,
footsie room,
you could probably climb under a stall if you're a small guy.
Right?
What's that?
As Minnesota?
Yeah.
I have a feeling it was Minnesota.
Minneapolis airport.
Larry.
Yeah.
Is he was apprehended by plain clothes police officer investigating complaints
of you would tap on it.
Yeah,
you would tap on something,
but that's just amazing that this guy is a Republican senator and he's doing gay
shit.
Or how about this?
Maybe he wasn't really doing gay shit and he had some fucking enemy and so some
enemy has him arrested for doing gay shit in the bathroom by a corrupt cop.
This,
it gets embarrassing.
Like if someone says you were sucking Dick in the bathroom,
man,
they could crush your reputation.
Listen to me.
If,
if somebody shoots boot over here and they come into the rest of me and I don't
have a fucking gun,
right.
They let me go
look at this.
The report,
allegedly according to the arrest report cited by roll call,
Craig tapped his right foot,
which the officer said he recognizes a signal used by persons wishing to engage
in lewd conduct.
How do you know maybe he's just got a song in his head.
He is then uh,
alleges that Craig then touch the officer's foot with his foot and the senator
proceeded a swipe his hand under the stall divider several times.
Maybe he's out of toilet paper.
He didn't want to talk about it.
Figured you'd be a gentleman handled some fucking toilet paper at that point,
the officer said he put his police identification down on the floor so Craig
could see it in a form.
The senator that he was under arrest.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You can't arrest someone for tapping their foot and putting their hand out.
Yes you can.
How can you arrest someone for that?
Yes,
you can.
Joe,
you would
be
at the airport.
I would definitely be as you saw my guerrilla foot with the fun guy.
Now come to
come to that thing and tap your foot and then my hand comes out and goes like
this,
look,
joke.
Like I'm squeezing it and nuts.
He's not going to dial nine one one.
I mean that's a pervert.
That's definitely a perfect,
I mean I'm not supporting this behavior but I just think you need a little bit
more than some sign language.
You get arrested and then weird.
I mean,
come on man.
Hillary Clinton,
she has a like a thousand emails that had classified information in them.
She doesn't get arrested.
This dude just taps his foot.
He gets arrested and 10 days in jail,
10 days.
Hmm.
Wow.
When I was like 18 there was a movie star bucks.
It's worth it.
It was real.
It was a movie theater,
not no work enough and it was like a regular suburb and we went there one night
and we thought it was like a rocky horror,
but it was like fucking straight up on,
it was like straight up queen liberty.
One of those places.
It was straight up porn and we went in there and we hung out for maybe 20
minutes somewhere.
You heard yelling and screaming to the bathroom dog.
Oh Jim,
we got the fuck out of.
That was the end of that shit.
He,
you could run into like the old days.
I can't deal with it yet.
In the old days Times Square,
you didn't want to fucking man.
Yeah,
I mean you were,
you were involved in madness.
Well,
Time's Square in the old days when people don't remember is that you have
Broadway,
let's go to the map.
You're filling them out of the,
and you had the eighth avenue,
which is probably the same,
I don't even fucking remember in those days.
But the movies started like here they were like g PG.
And then as you went up the block,
they got our that across the street towards the corner middle,
whether the acts devil and Mr. Jones,
you know,
uh,
that they had,
could be,
first of all,
in those days you couldn't have like a fucked up name,
like a comedic name.
You had to have a theatrical release name and point in the 70 [inaudible],
Linda Lovelace,
Lovelace.
You couldn't have like a spin off of something like,
it wasn't like they probably had out of the 12 or 13 movie theaters on both
sides.
They probably had more for movie theaters that were dedicated to straight up
fucking porn and they had one that was a split.
That was a movie on the way down to movies that were on the way down.
You know what I'm saying?
The Poseidon Adventure,
that Chinese connection there on the way down and then you had another movie
theaters actually played three movies on Sunday,
but then you had the good ones that play the James Bonds and you know the really
good ones,
but it was just always scary to go down there.
I used to always go down there,
Joe.
I bought ids down there.
I played three card Monte Donna,
I want it to one of the eighth grade.
I saw Paris busy owner.
He caught his neck on the fucking thing with April corridors and the and the
peep show.
Oh,
you told me that he stuck his neck and his head in there.
Let's head in that in those days they had three d,
You know I grew up down there,
you know,
I remember my friend buying weed and it was that sex.
We'd sex weed and the eighties you what?
Penthouse?
A playboy.
He had to be pent cause there were a little bit more.
If you bought a penthouse in the eighties the last two pages was dedicated to
fake weed and it was that.
It was just fuck.
That was one of the grossest things about those pot magazines.
They used to sell fake weed ads and they would just con suspecting unsuspecting
stoner stupid people.
And then they tell you don't open it to you.
Walk three blocks down.
Really are you?
If I just gave you 2150 I'm in the eighth grade.
I'm opening this motherfucker right here.
My buddy bought acid,
they gave him paper with coffee stains,
like little coffee but blotter acid like you got to be an ass.
So I like the word got out.
That was like amateur street of you went down to the Bot,
but that was the last 50 yards of the sex side,
like I said.
So on this side was just regular movies.
The mechanic,
a love bug,
you know,
it had an array of that style of movie.
Then across the street they would get a little bit more risque,
but sex world and towards the animal that block there was where Joe,
the 50 yards,
broad daylight,
cops down the corner and you can hear as you walked with your family,
you can be with your mom,
dad,
kids and that's all you would hit.
Marijuana acid brother.
I got cocaine,
I got some speed,
motherfucker.
I got tense.
I got fake ids selling it right out there.
Right out,
right out on that fucking 42nd street.
Daylight,
you know,
packed on a sat.
Saturday was suckers,
Paradise Suckers,
paradise and you would walk 50 yards and marijuana and [inaudible] oh yeah.
It didn't go but equal [inaudible] I have speed.
I got heroin and it was all beat because it's cops caught them.
It wouldn't even go to jam because it was fake.
Everything was fake.
Wow.
And then you hit the close getting all these tourists.
Yeah,
they were getting tourists.
Then you hit the corner and they would sit.
They would dissipate a little bit and then once you hit that street,
it would turn into three card Monte Ville.
Uh,
and then I knew a lot of guys who did that.
And then that's where three card Monte would get the tourists and you see people
crying and just crying.
And then after that it slowed up.
Excuse me.
Then the streets met,
but that was a hell fucking hole in the 80s a big Tgi Fridays.
Big Tgi Friday,
nothing goes down.
That's weird.
Nothing happens to Kim.
Like the place where like a top 40 TV shows film.
It became this like homogenized mall in the middle of New York City.
It's like the worst roughest part of New York City Times Square.
I mean that was 42nd street.
That was,
that was,
you know,
those,
there's like these iconic blocks,
you know,
hell's kitchen.
That was like right in their times square was like the place where all lewd
movies,
where Times Square was all the sex shops.
Times Square was all the chaos.
Great.
Now Times Square is like a Guy Fieri restaurant.
Six years ago you took me to New York City and you know we're from here.
So when we go back to New York,
we're not going to bed till three mammo.
We didn't even start thinking about bed till three o'clock in New York,
right?
Because it's midnight,
midnight or midnight.
Midnight is so I would fucking item,
it was four 30 in the morning.
I couldn't take it away.
I gotta go outside and rolled a joint.
These pictures,
Jamie's pulling up that I went to go full screen on that kick tracking thing.
I walked around for maybe 25 minutes and Joe Rogan,
I didn't see us soul.
Look at this video poker,
they had video poker,
pinball,
you play poker.
I don't remember.
Mardi gras.
This is just,
it's hilarious like that girls.
But you can,
we tolerated the tiny little butts back then.
You know,
and she's like,
look at all this today that their bet you'd be doing squats.
They changed the ass game somewhere around 2000 right?
The ass game pre 2000 and post 2000 I mean you want to talk about like errors of
greatness.
Like the the ass age is here if you want to like the acids of today are so
superior to the acids of our parents' generation.
I mean it's not even a fucking contest because in our parents' generation it
wasn't even a subject of debate.
It wasn't like who's got the best ass.
It took them years to figure that out.
It was tits.
Do you think of anything to do with those like magazines like maximum and stuff
that like they couldn't show nudity so they just have to show some sexy acids
with a little fun.
It's a very good point.
And they're all sports are oriented,
right?
So that's right around the two thousands and late nineties and it's,
you know,
what happened?
Check started lifting as soon as chick started lifting and you went whoa.
Like it made a big goddamn difference.
Mean,
there's always like standard meth measurements of beauty,
right?
Like small waist,
big hips,
you know,
hip to waist ratio,
facial features,
breast size.
You know,
something that makes women extraordinarily attractive to men.
Right?
But we,
I don't think we knew how much a big juicy ass really got people until like the
two thousands when the same me,
the late nineties the sixties and seventies who were breast people,
country when it was a different breast,
it was a real breasts to fucking pink was a lot bigger of the Arriola.
Whatever was huge and thick and you know,
it was,
and now it's become the,
the,
the breast skin tight call.
The fat's been cut off the breast.
That's what you look for now.
The woman's body has changed over the years.
If you look at a playboy from 1970s both of you guys,
you'll call me back and go,
what the fuck?
What people think?
And they're still beautiful,
but it's a different type of book.
They just weren't athletic.
If you look at the women in movies in the 60s they would drop dead.
Fucking gorgeous.
Yeah.
You had a fucking boat,
Derek.
She was like one of the first to have a tremendous ass,
but her body was just spectacular.
Bettie page had a pretty decent ass.
Hard to tell.
That girl needs to go to the gym.
Who's that?
Raquel Welch.
Her ass probably better now at 90.
Whose ass is that?
Whoa.
Quite flat,
unfortunately.
I wonder what,
what was the time now though?
What was the chick that flux are notches,
Heather.
I want to see what Audrey Hepburn.
No,
no,
no.
Not your head.
Think that went to fucking Paris.
Went up behind the,
who was exotic looking bitch.
I wonder what she was like in a bikini or she was stunning.
I was gonna say Tina Fey.
What the fuck am my team?
I gotta get Outta here,
man.
I got to go to the store.
What time is it right now?
It's 10 o'clock.
Joey Diaz.
All right,
let's do it tomorrow night.
Nine o'clock.
He KLT though.
What's the name of it?
Uh,
the car.
The Kia.
They,
the MGM.
You dirty freaks.
Ian Edwards hair.
She is,
who is it?
No,
that's not her.
I don't think that's her,
that's another one.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
That's,
I think that's his daughter.
You dirty son of a bitch.
Um,
he's got a,
he was an actress that he was in love with.
It didn't work out.
Whatever.
What are you going to do tomorrow?
Caught Theater.
Ian Edwards.
Joey Diaz.
And why?
We're fucking psyched.
I don't know how many times
your left.
It was almost sold out as of today.
Uh,
but uh,
and Joey,
what else you got coming up?
I know you are at the Ice House soon.
I saw your name up on the board.
Are you there next weekend?
Well,
ice house.
Pasadena?
No,
they had to cancel next weekend because of the surgery.
Oh,
I'm just doing isolated dates.
They got your name still up at the ice house.
Tell him to take your fucking name down.
It was supposed to have taken it.
There's a poster outside that's advertising.
You being there?
I pulled showing them.
Yeah.
I mean maybe it's a different date.
Do you have a date in the future there?
I got a date.
Uh,
maybe it's the August date they have up there.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe I knew you were going to be there and I knew you switch.
I don't know.
Maybe I fucked it up in my head.
All right.
I didn't know for sure.
Thank you very much.
Thanks everybody.
Thanks you too.
And then,
and uh,
we will be back on Monday with the great shale son and,
and,
uh,
it should be fun time talking to him,
especially because it's right after UFC 200 and I think jail has a new
submission organization.
He's going to do a professional submission,
a organization with Ebi rules,
which is the Eddie Bravo invitational rules,
the best rules and all of grappling.
So a exciting stuff.
So we'll talk to jail on Monday and that's it.
I see a little bit.
Hmm.